want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe
life and get some amazing motivation
from grant cardone
if you want to be in business for
yourself and free you must learn to
dominate
you cannot compete okay how many were
trained this
competition is a healthy thing that
message was not being delivered to
entrepreneurs
that message was being delivered to
consumers
there was somebody saying look the more
more oil companies we have the better
because it's good for the customer
right the more technology companies we
have it's not just microsoft
the better for the customer and into
inventions
and you know improvements and products
comes from competition
but if you're the one playing the game
you want to dominate the field
so look here's the deal i might be wrong
in what i say okay
i might be wrong in the things i do in
my life and the business that i started
my families told me not to start every
business that i've been involved in
every one of them every one of them was
a risk every one of them i had to
take a chance i remember my mom used to
tell me i wouldn't do that if i were you
i wouldn't do that if i were you i
wouldn't do that if i were you i'm like
mommy you wouldn't do anything
well you wouldn't do anything except be
the mother a great mother to five
children
my mother wasn't an entrepreneur she
didn't have my dreams just because she's
my mom doesn't mean she dreams like me
would you agree
okay my mom was wrong about everything
she told me not to do
love my mom to death okay unbelievable
friend of mine she was wrong
i needed to do those things okay steve
jobs needed to build this phone
would you agree did he help a lot of
people did he make some money while he
was doing it
119 billion dollars in five years
in the bank cash i'm not talking about
pro
i'm talking about in the in done in the
bank sitting there
okay brings a great product to the
marketplace domination or competition
total domination coca-cola competition
or domination
total domination okay exxon total
domination
you see what i'm saying you want to be
in a dominating point okay so what we
got to do is we got to get you thinking
we got to get you thinking like
the dominators think how do they act how
does warren buffett act what does warren
buffett do with his time all the time
those are the people i study today i
don't study the people that i went to
school with the teachers i went to
school with
i don't even study my own family members
okay
i'm looking for people that are way up
here that i can say hey what are they
doing because they're doing it right
you got to get some haters you need
haters
no school is going to teach you how to
get a hater
okay high school elementary school
colleges what do they teach you want to
be the most popular person no you want
haters
okay the companies that are hated are
the companies that are exploding
the people that are hated are the people
that explode
if i don't hate you if nobody hates you
nobody knows you
so the reason i'll tweet for instance
when we started we had this
uh that newsletter that i sent out okay
we sent it out every week
we were hitting people once a month and
we started getting complaints
you send stuff out too much my office
came to me
we went to twice a month they came to me
we have
more people pulling off of the
newsletter good
double up again why i want haters
okay so we started sending out one every
week and then i started a twitter
account
i actually had people write grant
cardone social media people
grant cardone is an example of what not
to do with social media i said freaking
just multiply just
increase it okay we were doing like four
tweets a day good do two an hour
why because i want my competition hating
my guts i want them talking about me i
mean i don't really want hate people to
hate me you understand what i'm saying
about
i want them so so energized that they
actually start pushing me
[Music]
they start promoting me i use every one
of the news channels if you
you'll see me on tv doing news one day
okay i don't i don't
watch news i make news see the shift
you see the slight shift don't watch the
news
decide when you leave here today to make
the news
right you don't read the newspaper you
write newspaper articles
you don't read books yeah read them but
learn to write them
and you know you don't need to take for
it you don't need to spend a lifetime
writing a book this was three hours
okay we sold 40 000 copies of this one
book and it was self-published it's
never
ever ever been in a bookstore
a guy writes me says man you got
misspelled words all in that book
i'm like yeah yeah what so what where
are they
123 128 134 165
120. i'm like yeah yeah and bad grammar
too
i'm like yeah what's your point dude
what's your point man why you keep
telling me that he's like
because man you got misspelled words in
a book it's a bestseller
okay so it ain't best written okay you
know what i'm not now
this work just so any nobody under i
don't want you to think that that's a
cuss word
the word look it up in the dictionary
means a complainer a whine or an excuse
maker
i wear a little band on my pen here on
my wrist here
it's a little black band and it says
champions
dominate and on the other side
don't be a little
that's right because i don't need it
i need to get rid of the whiners the
excuse makers oh my god it's the market
it's the market oh my god prices oh
inventory okay nine months ago there's
too much inventory now
too little inventory
human beings have so many excuses it's
unbelievable
you know why because you watch the news
too much
because you've agreed to receive news
not make news if you know what day it is
you are not busy enough i recently heard
this week oh it's monday man it's so
hard to get started on a monday i'm like
dude how do you even know it's monday i
don't know what day it is
on wednesday we hear it's humpback day
we're
halfway there so it's friday and it's
like oh
thank god it's friday or follow friday
or like dude
how do you people know what day it is
you're not busy enough you need to be so
freaking busy
that you don't know what time it is you
don't know if it's before lunch after
lunch before dinner after dinner
come on you've had those productive days
remember the day when you were so
productive
you you literally worked through lunch
and dinner
and you looked up at seven o'clock you
should have been home an hour ago and
you're like
dude i hadn't had lunch or dinner you
know why because
that day you were eating the marketplace
you were consuming the marketplace
because you were active
productive hitting it slamming creative
and completely committed look i don't
know what monday
wednesday or friday are i don't know
about saturdays and sundays i know this
create tremendous amounts of activity so
much activity
that you lose track of time your success
is not going to come from watching tv
or looking at a calendar your success is
going to come from
activity from being busy from being
obsessed from being
like so into it that you don't know
about
oh my gosh it's the monday morning blues
or wednesday humpback or
friday what i don't know friday what
whatever okay
get busy hey man how you doing buddy
good how are you
you got a book coming out don't you uh
you just came out
where can people get it get it on amazon
easiest spot
built to serve right there let's go man
if you guys don't know evan follow evan
carmichael
he's got a new book out build a server
go grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here in
different places
in life i promise you you're gonna find
you don't know where to go everybody
goes through this the most successful
people in the world
wake up some mornings with no clue
what to do today okay so first thing i
want you to know is that it's normal
it happens to everybody it's not like
you're a bad person or you're lost or
you're depressed or
you you got some problem you need to
take medication for
everybody everybody regardless their
stature in life
where they are regardless of their money
their relationship
their job they run the joint
promise you no matter how much they
present
like they look like they got the whole
package put together everybody
everybody has those days
and the sun is kicking today has those
days
where uh they don't know what to do
i don't know what to do you know
uncertainty
you you feel terrible my friend dale
christensen told me when i was
25 years old i was experiencing
depression every day he's like
no matter what man no matter what
no matter what dude show up even if your
eyes are bleeding
show up i've been doing that for 34
years now
show up even when i don't want to okay
and then what i try to do is i try to
help
one person one person
and what happened over the period of 34
years i did that every day
i'm not depressed anymore at least not
for long periods of time
i don't use any kind of medication don't
use any kind of drugs don't smoke weed
don't drink over
excessively drink i might have a drink
once in a while
and got a beautiful wife two beautiful
kids and for the most part my life is
freaking wonderful
all i did was this i don't over analyze
never do i label myself a loser a
quitter
um i'm hard on myself
i never i never label myself ocd acd
add ocdd whatever
a depressant uh alcohol like a drug
addict no no i don't this is what i do i
do things okay
show up move in the direction i don't
overanalyze move in the direction
that that that i think could be more
pro-survival than staying in one place
and number three
help somebody dude you don't get
attention today you have absolutely zero
chance
of being successful money follows
attention period into story you guys
that don't have time for facebook and
twitter and snapchat and instagram
you're like i ain't got time for all
that how many have said that before
you're like i ain't got time for all
that
i'm busy being broke i'm busy i'm busy
running my
into the ground i'm busy i'm busy with a
bunch of old lies and old ideas
i'm busy paying for my house note for
the next 27 years stuck in one place and
i can't move to jobs
when did your life change look it
changes every day
so and and then and then you got to add
change on top of that how are you going
to get to mars
right well you're going to build a ship
you're going to probably blow up the
first two or three of them
and then you're going to stay focused on
the task get people around you that
don't make excuses get rid of people
that do
and then you're going to be like hey
we're going to mars dude no matter what
it takes what it cost
and and you got to keep feeding the
dream you know and so that's what i've
done dude
like from eight years old like eight
seven eight years old i've just been
feeding the beast and when i quit
feeding the beast of my dreams and
fantasies
when i quit giving them energy what
happened was i started feeding other
demons
and and my my life went downhill so by
the time i'm 25 i'm broke i'm wrecked
i'm
spiritually bankrupt i'm physically
bankrupt i hate myself
and then but i didn't quit you know
jared i just had to start rebuilding
from zero
i was broke when i was 25
dead broke i'm not talking about
financially bro let me tell you
something no i didn't have any money in
my pocket
i didn't have any credit cards nobody
would give me credit okay
didn't have a driver's license okay 1970
ford maverick had a 1970 ford maverick
no air
no heat no door handles the floor was
rusted
okay i lived in a 275 square foot
apartment maybe 300 square feet
if you counted the little step out in
the front of the front door
i paid 275 a month and i was late almost
every month
so don't tell me about your money
problems man okay don't tell me about
where you were born
don't tell me about your bad breaks
don't tell me about what your daddy did
or your uncle felt you up or something
did some kind of weird thing to you know
i'll ruin your head or your sister
abused you or whatever okay
look we all got problems you got to fix
your problems now you got to get your
money right
so 25 years old i'm like i'm getting my
money right i'm done no more excuses
no more crybaby no more blame i'm
getting my freaking money right i've
spent the last 30 years doing that and
now i want to help you do the same thing
all right
get your money right that i did was i
started studying people
that did more not people that
didn't do more not people that said do
less not people that said hey don't be
satisfied
or be satisfied not people that said hey
be grateful for what you have
i started studying people that said
and had done more that you can do more
that's who i listen to today i listen to
the people my friends in my life the
people i listen to the people i talk to
the people that i follow on facebook
or or youtube or instagram i don't
follow everybody
i follow the people that say you can do
more dude i follow the people that say
i am doing more i follow the people that
are
actually doing something on this planet
to make a difference for the better
you have to be selective you have to
give something up okay you cannot listen
to everybody
to every voice to every person has quit
or given up
you got to make a decision if you have
that little voice inside of you that
says you can do more you have to
to give attention to that voice
and you got to feed it with those
that support that idea that you can do
more i remember
my dad my dad died when i was 10 years
old he didn't have a problem with work
he said work is good
he said more work is better he said lots
of work is even better than that and if
you could get a whole bunch of people
working together
you could actually accomplish something
now fast forward
you know to to somewhere in the last 20
years work
became an addiction like oh my god
you're a work addict
you're a compulsive work person you're
over achiever
you have problems in your life i'm like
dude the only problem i got in my life
is that you telling me work is a
bad thing the more i work the better i
am the more i get accomplished the
happier i am
the more i work in the more accomplished
the better i feel about myself
i'm not trying to fill up a hole i'm
trying to get my reach my potential
okay check this out 22 out of 28 million
small businesses in america
have no employees zero employees what
kind of business is that man
i am the master and the slave
i am the prisoner the warden the
jailhouse the system
dude you're stuck that's not a business
you cannot do the solopreneur thing
even though you see some guy on
instagram rolling out with a lambo
okay it's [ __ ] that's not a business
a business is people in a company
anybody know any major successful person
that
that didn't have a bunch of employees
anybody here know
any great company that had one employee
one flow of income that didn't use debt
okay caterpillar debt coca-cola
debt ford motor company debt they had to
use
debt you got to use debt to expand you
can't stay
small and expect the world to know you
it's impossible
for me successes is freedom
like at the end of the day i want
freedom my money's great but money just
gets this freedom
right so i see a lot of my peers in fact
a friend that i was doing business with
a couple years ago he said to me he's
like grant you're the freest guy i know
this guy's extremely wealthy worth multi
billions of dollars
he says you my friend are the freest guy
i know
so what do you mean by that it just came
out of nowhere
you say what you we'd spend a lot of
time together and he's like i've been
with you now for about
a month and a half you say what you want
you do what you want
you know there's going to be
consequences it's clear that you're
consciously aware that you're saying
something that's going to affect
somebody
he's like you're not stupid you know
what you're doing i see you on youtube
facebook twitter instagram
snapchat he didn't even know what most
of these was he he says i see you say
what you want
as often as you want willing to make
mistakes
she sees it too right so she knows that
we go into environments and she's gotten
even used to
the fact that i'm gonna have my opinion
i'm gonna go research things that other
people might find controversial
i'm gonna dig into things that people
are like saying no
about will cross the line for me it's
about freedom it's about can i go where
i want
can i do business with who i want this
is what i've always wanted in my life
i want to go where i want i don't want
to be fixed in one spot i want to be
able to move
my first 10 years of my life i remember
going being on one plane with my mom my
dad and my brothers
and sisters we went on one trip in 10
years
before that we knew i never dude i never
been on a trip we sat and coach
and and we flew to los angeles and we
went to disneyland okay and every time
we were every time we looked at
something everything was too expensive
so and i was tripping out all i knew was
the people that had the money had the
control
they decided when we went to the mickey
mouse pancake shop what rides we could
be
on and and you know fast forward to
today you know i know i don't stand in
line when i go to
to disneyland i'm like hey what do i
have to pay so i don't have to stand in
line
my dad could have probably done that too
but he wasn't
he didn't go to the next level and and
for him
for my parents you know you made money
you saved money you protected money
and that was good but but it's not the
only solution
my dad stopped my dad stopped at save
the money
and let's go on a trip you know
rather than hey you know what let's keep
building let's keep growing let's be
obsessed with something
monster not just enough
and and and because my dad was satisfied
with enough he died at 52.
i know maybe he'd have died at 52 the
other way too but when you scale out
dude you can actually live longer
because you're not doing all the work
anymore what do you not know about money
you need to ask yourself that what is it
you don't know about money
you live on a planet that has
endless amounts of paper
[Music]
you have plenty of sticky sticky
notepads everybody agree with that
i mean how many of you are short on
legal pads
[Music]
or are sticky notes or
ear swabs or cotton swabs
you're not short on any of that stuff
everybody everybody has plenty of that
stuff except maybe the
people in puerto rico that by the way
that's a good example of what can happen
to good people
bad things happen to good people
and money money solves some of those bad
things from happening to them would you
agree
okay now if you didn't leave puerto rico
and you knew a cat 5 storm was coming or
irma was coming to
to to florida or harvey was coming to
houston
right or you live in los angeles and you
know there's earthquakes
and you don't have a plan
what is it you don't know like like
you're not stupid you're not
dumb and you're not lazy you're a bunch
of entrepreneurs in a room
that want to do something big you would
not come to this conference if you did
not want to scale your business
the question was asked the other night
why do you want to scale you all have to
scale
you have to scale for this one reason
right here you need money
you need money okay why do i need money
what don't i know about money why are
people struggling with money you should
ask yourself these questions
why are you coming up short on money
is it what you know or what you don't
know
how many of you know this saying
knowledge is
okay how many of you agree with that how
many agree knowledge is power
so look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge
could the wrong knowledge be power
over you right see what i'm saying
so like when you set your business up
how many of you set your business up you
you know about
uh uh the the average entrepreneur solo
premier makes about
42 000 bucks a year and the average
american makes 58.
this guy left a job to make less money
so he could say hey i'll work for myself
me and gary vaynerchuk had this
conversation he's like look somebody's
better off making 42 for themselves than
making 42 for somebody else i said dude
ain't nobody better off making 42.
okay see this is what you need to
understand the first thing you've got to
you got to decide now sean says he
doesn't chase a number i'm chasing a
number
why would you have a target on
everything in life and not have one on
money
every athlete has a target
right every professional has a target
every department and every company every
division i have has a target
no target means what what is your target
right
if i have no target i'm successful i
will hit the zero target
a a guy's homeless out there hey begging
for food can you give me some food can
you give me some food i give him food
he's like no no no i don't really want
the food i really want
dude just say it on the sign bro
give me a hundred just change the ask
but you gotta have a target you gotta
have a target
this is the secret of the successful
people this is what i've committed my
life to doing
i told my mom when i was 16 years old
one day
one day i'm going to be successful one
day one day i'm going to be successful
and one day i'm going to help a lot of
people i always say this pay the price
today
so you can pay any price in the future
pay the price
now okay pay the price
my buddies were traveling seeing the
world and i didn't have any of those
experiences
i've had people tell me hey you mark it
too much
you mark it too aggressively take me off
your list
my office tells me we hit the list too
much
i'm like what's a list for hit the list
that's what it's for there's a eight
eight billion people on planet earth
look i've been ridiculed by my peers by
customers
and by competition i've been judged for
working too much
wanting too much being too colorful
being inappropriate
insensitive and too out there i'm trying
to figure it out i've been threatened
i've been sued
i've been betrayed by friends i've been
ripped off and i've been
copied 30 years
30 years 18 hour days not eight hour
days not 10 hour days
not 12 hour days 18 hour days
it's been 30 years 30 years it's
probably going to be 30 years for you
too
doubt uncertainty insecurities
rejection disappointment judgment it's
going to be 30 years of it
are you willing to pay the price
are you willing to pay the price
if anybody thinks you're going to be
successful without paying that price
you're wrong you got to get up you got
to get out the amount of time you spend
outside your proximity or
location where you sleep gives you a
better chance of being successful
so get up get out go meet the world head
on folks no matter how bad it is
okay you got you got reputation problems
you got i feel bad problems
you got friend problems you got money
problems whatever the problems are
okay try this
just get up and get out and go meet the
world head on
go meet whatever it is okay you got to
make up to somebody you got to apologize
for something you've done
you got to make up the damage of of
years of neglect and
and maybe uh betrayal and look i've done
all that
i've had all those things where i
screwed up over and over and over again
my reputation sucked
i was 20 between the ages of 15 and 25
years old
it was like i was doing everything i
could just to damage
damage my reputation okay if it made me
look bad i did it
so here today i'm gonna spend 10 days 14
days something like that
up here with that view
you can fix anything i'm proof that you
can fix anything anything
can be fixed anything can be fixed but
you got to fix it
you got to fix it you can't just sweep
it under the old rug
you got to fix it you gotta clean up the
damage
you gotta pay the price clean up your
debts
do what you say you're gonna do become
the most dependable person
in your space become the go-to person
oh i can put that person on stage and
know exactly what they're gonna get for
me
i can put that person in the game and i
know what play they're gonna run
i can put that person on the floor and i
know they're gonna get it done
be the go-to person okay you don't need
to be funny
you don't need to be entertaining all
the time you don't need to be the person
you're talking about you need to be the
go-to person folks
if you're going to make mistakes in your
life make them fast
right you're going to lose a deal make
them lose the deal fast if you're not
going to make any money on the deal
make sure the deal is quick right how
many made no money on a deal this month
but it took four hours that's stupid man
you see most of you in a room
unfortunately you listen to the media so
much you think you're
you think you're you're everything's
good you think you're fine okay
because the media has not exposed the
reality
on the middle class they talk about
poverty and they talk about the rich
people and they never talk about the
people in between
the people in between in this country
suffer more than the people in poverty
people in poverty are actually taken
care of people in the middle are
completely ignored
i'm talking about the people that make
200 grand a year and live up here
and still don't have any money left over
they send their kids to school they got
two bmws
they live in a nice house they have air
conditioned water and heat
right and there's no money so they send
a little bit of money to a keo account
and they think okay we're gonna retire
one day you're gonna be old one day
by the time you get to use that money
you'll be so old you won't want to use
it
the only thing that's going to change
anything for you and your family is like
man what am i doing here
okay you don't need to go work in
another industry you take the habits you
have right now to the restaurant
business the restaurant business will
fail
every business is in disruption right
now everything is changed you want to go
do you want to go trade bitcoin
it's going to take a commitment it's
going to take ups and downs
going to be a bunch of ups and downs in
that crypto play everybody agree
yeah okay you want to go do the real
estate game rather than a card game
i'm gonna tell you something right now
man if you don't bring commitment and
discipline
and and and fortitude and persistence to
the real estate game you will get killed
in the real estate game
there's no game that you're gonna win at
that doesn't require
a commitment single biggest mistake i've
made in my career was not spending money
it's what put me in a position to be
able to buy real estate
because i had money but i had to buy the
real estate i had to use the money
bradley made a comment the other day
about
money money is not to be saved and
hoarded like
like it's no good if you don't use it
this is the problem with bitcoin
when did when do i transact with it
right i'm sitting on a million dollars
by the bitcoin right now
i can't get rid of it fast enough i
can't go buy stuff with it so until that
that that situation is resolved right
it's why people don't hoard
gold anymore you don't keep gold because
you can't exchange it
money is to be used for those of you out
there that are like complaining about
the cost of anything the truth is that's
what that money's for
the only thing the only purpose money
has
is to be used and and i was scared
that i couldn't produce more money so
every time i spent money i complained
about it
today i'm like that's the biggest
mistake i ever made should have been
spending more money
it wouldn't take taken me 30 years in
the first five years i should have
borrowed money i didn't have
and i should have spent money that i did
have and i should have gone into debt to
do it
to get my brand out there to get it
known the mattress guy in your town did
it
the car guy in your town did it whoever
spent the most money
whoever whoever put it all out there all
the time every day on every tv
radio and the internet wins the battle
it's not the prettiest guy
okay
[Music]
it's not it's the guy that out
advertises you that outspent you
it takes courage to make money hey a
quick uh quick note out to
all of you out there that believe that
an open mind is important which by the
way i agree with you i agree and open
minds important you know the old saying
the mind is like a parachute it won't
work if it's open
but i want you to add one piece to that
if that parachute is wide open
you're falling straight to the ground
you understand what i'm saying if it
doesn't open
if the mind doesn't open you're in
trouble if it opens too wide
your dead man bouncing or a dead woman
bouncing my point to you
is this okay most people do actually
have an open mind
the problem is many people
they have a mind that's wide open with
no filters no
gates no protection you listen to
everyone you listen to everyone on
facebook
everyone on instagram you listen to your
uncle your aunt your mom
your dad when the mind's too open you
get too much data
and you go into confusion how important
is it to have that team and
and to all those who are watching that
are starting off their teams what would
be the advice that you would give them
yeah well the the whole solopreneur
thing i'm going to do it by myself i'm
going to work from home that's
it's not even real like i know it's
popular you see it on instagram
and you think some guy's doing something
on instagram he's not doing anything
dude he's posted
he posted an image of his car that he
watches on instagram
okay okay it might not even be his car
by the way
okay he's rubbing out his car and posted
somebody else's car
he posted a picture of edwin's car as he
passed up here in the hills
so uh after he freaking mowed my lawn
so um what would i tell you dude you got
to be on a team i mean like like
how are you going any place by yourself
you live on a planet with seven billion
people
you're like i hear people say all the
time i don't i you know i'm an ex i'm an
introvert
and i don't like people do you live on
planet earth
okay kind of the wrong place to enter so
you know people i know people that can't
swim man
i'm like two-thirds of the planet is
water
ain't jumping this floor you might want
to get your stroke zone dog
i mean there's a chance in your lifetime
that you're going to need people
and you might need a backstroke right
you
might need to be able to hold your
breath at some point so so like i don't
understand why people aren't getting
prepared we live on a planet that is
basically it's got gravity on it it's
got an atmosphere
and there's one common thing whether
you're chinese hispanic i don't think
hispanics even a group is it not latinos
latinos man okay okay sorry man okay you
got blacks you got whites you got
italians you got all these people right
koreans
you got we got all these people but the
truth is man economics bind us all
together
okay i go down to the grocery store and
there's a somebody from korea in there
i'm trading money with that person okay
that that is the exchange
you're on a team your team can be your
team that has
the goal they want to go get is to sell
hit a target
but part of your team is also the people
you're selling to
and part of your team is also another
team is the community you live in
and another another team is your church
you know and your family and these are
all teams right
and your job and my job i mean if you
want to be all alive
all in the deal your job is to keep all
you need to be a
super champion of all these teams not
just one team
how many of you want to make more money
[Music]
pay attention then you can't make more
money if you don't know what we're doing
here
so the first thing is to decide hey am i
in the right place those guys had to
walk in that stadium last night and say
hey we in the right place yeah man okay
and then they probably said man we got a
shot here we got a chance to win a super
bowl
right you came to work today this is not
a super bowl
unless you want it to be but i'm gonna
tell you something if you don't get your
life ready right now if you don't start
acting right now like you're in the
super bowl you're never gonna make one
anyway
even when you do make one i mean if you
look at that kid last night what's his
name uh
nick paul he's been sitting on the
sidelines for years overlooked for years
what you do right now every day
even if you hate your job i promise you
promise you this will happen in your
life
if you could learn how to embrace every
moment like this is a super bowl
one day you're going to get your shot
you're going to get your shot but you're
not
your shot will not show up if you're not
ready because even if you
even if it shows up if you're not ready
you won't be able to see it so you know
what i do every time i'm having trouble
every time i'm like man i don't think i
can get to where i'm going
i just start looking at the top i don't
look at the bad facts all i do is i
start searching
tell me about wealthy people facts about
wealthy people anything what are they
doing what are they buying it just gets
me out of my problem right
it gets me to think bigger you know the
the first plane i bought i bought this
plane because i saw other wealthy people
making moves i'm not an irresponsible
person okay
like i have always been a very frugal
person but the frugal was hurting me
not helping me so you live what part of
mexico you live in
how rich you can get has something to do
with who you're hanging with
how rich you can think has something to
do with who you're hanging with
okay how smart you are has something to
do
with your surroundings if you hang out
with dumb people you're gonna end up
dumb
if you hang out with junkies you're
gonna end up being a junkie you hang out
with criminals
i'm not talking about the people that go
to jail i'm talking about all the people
at your office right now
that cheat their employer and cheat
themselves you hang out with crim crims
you end up being a crim if you want to
build a network number one thing
commit to building a network a network
by definition is
not if you're building a new network
it's not the people you're already with
it's how do i add people to my network
so number one you got to commit to
building a network number two
who do you want in the network
who is it most of you just go for more
people like you have already in your
network
i want new people new characters
new personalities new thinking new ideas
the old adage if you're the smartest
person in the room
you in the wrong room
and number three when you start building
this network up and you start meeting
the people
okay number two is who do you want to
meet who who are you gonna add to the
network you go nine thousand people in a
room you don't need to meet all nine
thousand you need to meet maybe a list
of
30 or 40 people who do you want to meet
number three
when you meet them focus on them not on
you it shouldn't be
here's my card i'm a chiropractor this
is what i do
can i give you an adjustment dude it
should be like
who are you how can i help you what are
you doing where do you
live okay what projects are you working
on
how can i help you so i was a car
salesman when i was 25 years old with an
accounting degree i was the only
accounting degreed
car salesman in the state of louisiana i
hated myself for it
i make it three grand a month nobody
would hire me as an accountant one out
of four jobs in
in louisiana you couldn't get one out of
four people 25
unemployment and i just said how do i go
from three grand to four grand that's
all i want to know
but i started paying attention okay who
can get me that money i don't have it
who's got it i needed shoes i needed
jeans
right i needed a new shirt i had these
white shirts i'm a car salesman i need
nice clean
crisp white shirts people believe in me
i need some training i don't know how to
talk to people
i hate sales i hate it still hate it
today
i've made hundreds of millions of
dollars providing sales of programs to
corporations
i hate sales so the fact that i hated it
didn't mean i i don't do it because
you're only going to be paid two ways
your whole life you will never be paid
fairly
ever so give up the whole i'm not being
paid fairly [ __ ]
you will never ever be paid fairly
you're going to be underpaid most of
your life
and then one day if you're lucky you'll
be overpaid i'm going to tell you
something when i made four grand that
was the most important money that i've
ever made in my entire life
no money has ever made me happier than
that thousand dollars because that
thousand dollars made me realize
i can do anything single biggest mistake
i've made in my career was not spending
money
it's what put me in a position to be
able to buy real estate
because i had money but i had to buy the
real estate i had to use the money
bradley made a comment the other day
about money
money is not to be saved and hoarded
like like
it's no good if you don't use it this is
the problem with bitcoin
when did when do i transact with it
right i'm sitting on a million dollars
by the bitcoin right now
i can't get rid of it fast enough i
can't go buy stuff with it so until that
that that situation is resolved right
it's why people don't hoard
gold anymore you don't keep gold because
you can't exchange it
money is to be used for those of you out
there that are like complaining about
the cost of anything the truth is that's
what that money is for
the only thing the only purpose money
has
is to be used and and i was scared
that i couldn't produce more money so
every time i spent money i complained
about it
today i'm like that's the biggest
mistake i ever made should have been
spending more money
it wouldn't have taken taken me 30 years
in the first five years i should have
borrowed money i didn't have
and i should have spent money that i did
have and i should have gone into debt to
do it
to get my brand out there to get it
known the mattress guy in your town did
it
the car guy in your town did it whoever
spent the most money
whoever whoever put it all out there all
the time every day on every tv
radio and the internet wins the battle
it's not the prettiest guy
okay
it's not it's the guy that out
advertises you that outspent you
it takes courage to make money and i
said to her i said look the thing that i
do at my company
that is very unusual is that we are
completely unreasonable
without reason without we don't use
yes i'm logical okay yes i'm a sane
person
but when it comes to achieving a target
we
we do it with like we abandon
reason and logic we don't talk about
yeah but we never start yeah but or no
we can't or we couldn't because
or it didn't happen because any any time
you're talking anytime you're making
sense of why something didn't work we
don't have the budget
we can't do that because yeah but we're
different
you are being reasonable the great
things that have happened on this planet
and continue to happen are because
people are unreasonable
they literally abandon reason and logic
they defy the universe now if you look
around if you're a logical person if
you're a person who has to make sense of
it beforehand
then spend some time looking around the
universe look at nature look at all the
things that are done
every day that literally defy gravity
defy possibility defy physics
it's all over the place if you need to
be reasonable
now in my case i don't need to be
reasonable because there's enough
cases of super successful people doing
things that are amazing whether it was a
manufacturing a new product
or whether it was steve jobs coming back
to apple and turning that company around
every day every look at amazon look what
amazon has done
okay now you look at it you're like dude
that's a no-brainer
make ever make all products available
online
now it's a no-brainer now it's like it's
so logical look at velcro
velcro was like god i i should have
thought of that
see but beforehand it was completely out
of
reason that you could stick things
together
uh because they scratch one another you
understand what i'm saying so look this
is what i want you to try
try this in your life it's gonna be very
difficult it's one of the most difficult
things i do is being unreasonable
because all the people i'm surrounded by
are trying to make sense of why they
can't do something
quit making sense of why you can't do
something and become unreasonable
until you do do something what are you
going to do when you wake up and you
feel
lost you feel less than you feel you
feel a sense of
uh either depression or despair
and no direction what i do is this
i show up i show up man
buddy of mine told me when i was at the
at a low super low point in my life
he said hey man show up even if your
life's
if your eyes are bleeding and your life
is low
show up anyway show up bigger is better
how many
agree with this okay if you can live on
900 grand
the only people that won't go to 9
million are the people that are selfish
unselfish people grow their businesses
selfish people don't
okay if you're taking notes if you're
gonna walk away with something today
i'm talking to the able people here give
me the name of a great company that has
seven employees
i'm waiting give me the name of a great
company that doesn't spend a load of
money on advertising
who is this company tell me give me one
name one name of any company that's
great
this small
see see you you built a business on a
fantasy
right like i'm going to get a state form
i'm going to get a state form i'm going
to get an all-state company
i'm i'm going to be an all-state guy and
i'm going to make 900 grand a year
you're selfish folks
see what i'm saying about the selfish
person makes what they need
the unselfish person says i'm going to
make more than i need
i've been lost most of my life literally
the first 45 years of my life
the first probably 51 years of my life
first 45 years for sure i was completely
lost
and uh somewhere between 45 and 51 i
started figuring out okay what am i
doing i started sorting my life out i
started getting some
started doing some courses that really
really made a difference in my life
i've always been in a self-improvement
my whole life
and but it wasn't until i was about 45
that i really started discovering
information that could make me more
confident
me more sure you know when i was 25
years old i was a young sales person and
i didn't like sales
and and i got educated on how to sell
and i became
very very good at it
[Music]
i started understanding the process the
customer the objections the rebuttals
how to follow up
how to handle the rejection and the
disappointment to discourage how to get
over it but that didn't help me become
more confident in me as a person as an
individual i was making money
by the time i was 31 i had a couple
businesses
they were making money probably had you
know
three four hundred thousand dollars
saved when i was 30 31 years old
because i was trying to make a little
money right by the time i'm 33 i got a
probably a million dollars in a bank i
still didn't feel good about myself
i had this nagging nagging like
sense of desperation anxieties
depression
uncertainty a lack of confidence
and
when i started working on me spiritually
that's that's when
that's when like 45 46 47 years old
that's when everything changed for me
like everything all the expansion the
the confidence the
getting out in the world uh maybe a
little better communicating than i was
doing i'm not perfect at it by any means
now
and i started getting more certainty
about who i am what i am
where i'm going and why i'm here like if
you don't figure those things out no
amount of money
no amount of money in the world will
will fill you up no
the private planes won't the fancy cars
you have to know where you're going how
do you do this
i started with one employee his name was
grant cardone
i knew him and so i hired him right
he passed a drug test i believed in him
and for 15 years i was one guy and then
one day i woke up a guy actually
a mentor of mine said look you can't
scale
with just yourself you got to start
building a business here if you're going
to have a real business you need
employees you need people
you need to be willing to hire people
and i'm like man man i'm scared
they cost money he's like not making
sales one
two three four these empty desks
that's what's costing me money okay
that's what's costing you money
staying small is costing you money okay
all this costs money i have failures
here i have disappointments i have
discouragements i have people that work
here for a little while and quit
but you're not going to get big by
yourself if if you ask me to coach your
business
i'm not going to think about how to hold
on to what you did last year that's what
most people right now are thinking here
in march
in january you were like this is going
to be a great year by march you're like
man i just want to do what we did last
year if we just do you're starting to
make sense you're becoming reasonable
okay i'm telling you that because this
is what your people do too
okay your people the people that you
hire they make sense of how to make 48
grand a year
and if you have people in your company
they're trying to make sense of how to
make 48 grand a year you got a company
that's gonna die
toys r us file bankruptcy this week
iheartradio the biggest radio
station in the world filed for
bankruptcy this week there's gonna be
massive disruption in the marketplace
why because these companies thought
about they they kept they kept
having trophies about what they had
rather than what would what they could
get
who's got money who's qualified to buy
how can i get their attention how can i
tell them what i want from them
okay how fast can i get to the
marketplace fast
speed is the new big you can do more
you can do more than you ever imagined i
was broke at 25 years old
broke okay every two years i get one of
these cars
the people at rolls-royce is like i want
to send you another one of those cars
okay
how you want it how you want to dress
what color you want it like it's crazy
it's crazy the life i'm living right now
we did a
we did a conference it was 10 000 people
in the room and another 10 000 people
online
all of them paid to be there i remember
when
i couldn't get two people to show up at
a party in high school
because i was so disliked you can do
more than you think you can it's my
message to you today you will live
longer than you think i promise you okay
you can do more than you think you can
if you're not going to work like a
10-hour day is a short day for me
i hear more people promoting this four
hour idea
okay like tim ferriss i just call him
out right now it is complete bunk
it is complete you cannot sk you cannot
outsource everything this idea that
you're going to be a solopreneur
outsource or work four hours or
part-time you guys try to do the
part-time thing
you will have full-time problems forever
for the end of
the end of your life not only will you
have problems because you're selfish if
you're trying to do a four-hour work
week
you're selfish you're thinking only
about yourself if you don't scale and
hire people you're also selfish you're
trying to manage money rather than
saying
hey i have a great message like you you
have an obligation man
to get out there and help people so
i don't know how to do 10 hours i know
how to
i know i need six to seven maybe eight
hours of sleep a day
the question is how am i going to best
utilize my other 16 hours
with my family as a father as a
community leader as somebody that's
interested in changing the conditions
around me right
and how can i use that phone to maximize
those 16 hours
and how can i spend time with my kids
that actually
adds value to my business right how can
i create
a studio so me and my wife can work
together on wednesdays
like everything that we do here is about
my life so that i'm dropping stuff into
my life bucket
my work gets dropped in here so it's
like everything i do i go on a trip i go
look at real estate
i do an interview uh i i set up a house
with
uh in deer valley for a month i have
people come over
investors i look at real estate
everything is basically
i'm i'm i'm i'm what is it uh uh you're
charting
yeah exactly inside a soup right i'm
making a meal called my life
and that's what i would tell people to
do quit thinking about how little you
can do
and start thinking about how much how
much how many different things can i do
in the same day i'm going to save money
this is what you hear if you look on the
internet how do i make money first thing
you got to do is you got to save money
what do you hear the politicians say the
middle class i'm here to save it
what if there is no middle class and it
was just made up
to keep the people civil see
see that that's how you're going to play
this game you got to be available
people have to know you don't talk to
strangers
strangers got everything you want man
everything you want a stranger's got it
[ __ ] your friends ain't got nothing
right if it's up to your friends you
you're done
you're like oh my friends are broke i'm
25 years old everybody around me was
broke okay
my mama was scared every time my mama
tuesday tuesday she's clipping coupons
that was the reason to get the newspaper
the coupons are coming she would sit
there and clip a man she had him in the
little box i learned that for you
for 16 years i watched my mom do that
for 16 years my mom would tell me hey
grant turn those lights off turn those
lights off
me and my twin brother turn those lights
off from across the house
she could hear me walk out of my bedroom
75 feet away and say hey turn those damn
lights off
i told you okay twin brothers okay i'm
16 years old my twin brother
my mom said when you guys go pee do it
together
saves water saves water right
okay when my mom fed me because mama i
had a great mom
how many of you had great parents give
you give your parents a great hand huh
hey just because they were great parents
doesn't mean they weren't confused
right because my mama was confused man
my mom did not know how to make money
she had no education she had no ability
she had never held a job she did not
know how to get money
so what she had to do was protect the
little bit of money she had
sell or be sold she was sold on
conservation
reduce risk don't spend contract protect
it defend it
you understand diversify have a lot of
little bets all over the place okay
lots of little bets you should never
have a lot of bets all over the place
until you're extremely wealthy
when you're trying to get wealthy you
want to literally you want to go all in
and it not be a vet you need to know the
space so well
that you're like i know for sure this is
going to work what do you know will pay
you
every time make decisions quickly
so that i can sell things quickly
because if you do it if you do it
if you do it a certain way you give
yourself permission to ask
other people to do the same thing
it's built-in ethics uh at the end of
the last year
on december the 13th the 14th captain
ryan's in a row
i said dude we're gonna buy a plane by
the end of the year
okay okay i'm gonna wipe out my tax bill
i'm gonna buy a damn plane and we're
gonna wipe it out okay i bought a plane
in less than
nine days brand new plan in nine days
the guy gulfstream says dude nobody does
this most people take nine months some
people take nine years
they nine days we bought the plane
bought it shopped it bought it closed it
he's like nobody does that it's
ridiculous huge purchase big purchase
typically a very long cycle a lot of a
lot of shopping guarantee you that
decision that quickly would make me a
lot of money
you understand why that's how i make
decisions man so what do i expect you
guys to make decisions the same way
i spent 50 million bucks in
90 minutes and you guys take in
nine months to spend six grand
make decisions quick make decisions as
fast as you can stay
certain you can get new money everybody
agree see when i do that in my own life
i can press you to do the same thing
i've given myself permission and in this
universe giving myself permission
to push people to do things faster if
you take a long time to do things
your buyer will then be allowed to take
a long time to do things you shop a
second place a third place a fourth
place a fifth place a sixth place guess
what
they will too you gotta get a best deal
because your daddy taught you to get a
good deal
never be taken advantage of shop two and
three places
get your best discount it's got to be on
sale
then guess what every customer you have
is gonna what
give me a deal man give me a deal man
give me a deal man okay
your worst customers are the ones you
give the best deal to
[Applause]
never can make them happy they want
something oh give me something extra
give me something else the mooch
never satisfied right or wrong because
you guys are mooches
you guys are mooches just be honest man
you can't fix what you deny
you're a mooch they're going to be a
mooch they're cheap they're going to be
cheap
you're cheap they're gonna be cheap you
take a long time they're gonna take a
long time
you shop four or five places they're
gonna do the same thing you need more
information they're gonna do the same
thing
you gotta have your wife involved
they're gonna do the same thing
everybody's trying to go out there and
not sell you guys are all trying like
i'm gonna
i'm gonna be talented talent does not
win
i know a whole bunch of guys less
talented than me
that beat me for years they beat me
because they got exposure
in the marketplace some of those names
just in different sectors
okay in real estate okay i got a there's
a group that that they went out and
bought a hundred and forty thousand
units um you know i got for 4 500.
they're not as good they they make take
a lot of shortcuts they don't take care
of the tenant as well as i do but they
thought way bigger than i did
so um you know what i'm saying like it's
in different spaces there was an
automotive space that i was in for years
i was the leader in the automotive space
me and another guy constantly combating
right he had a garbage product
he sold for less than i did he
he scaled better than i did he beat me
at the scale game so
you can't see a lot of people say look
look man steve jobs started his business
in a garage
uh the the i think cadillac's got a
commercial where the cadillac was
created in a garage
who else bill gates started his business
in a garage
mark zuckerberg started facebook in a
dorm
everybody's like oh my god man i can do
this from home none of those companies
got big
when they stayed in the garage in the
dorm markey z
didn't make it until he moved to silicon
valley and built a team okay google
didn't become
google until they had a campus in
silicon valley and they scale to
tens of thousands of employees so you
have to scale to be great
so would you say then for the average
entrepreneur out there as they are as
they're growing their business getting
those sales
they should definitely be setting some
of that income aside you should you
should be source
yeah you should not be thinking about
what you can live on
right i made eight grand this month man
all of its net profit
all that money should be reinvested in
people so that that's why people think
incorrectly that's why i always go back
to this argument about look these
solopreneurs are selfish
almost like a little selfish child right
i'm gonna go out i left my job i was
making 90 grand now i'm gonna me and
gary vaynerchuk had this conversation
i was making 90 grand now i'm going to
work for myself and make 90 grand and
gary's like well yeah the guy's better
off the guy's better off working
for himself for 90 grand than working
for somebody else and i'm like dude
nobody's better off working for 90
grand you can't live on 90 grand not
today you can't
no anywhere in america there's nowhere
in america you live in for 90 grand
in miami you're going to have 12 000
before taxes
left over at the end of the year if you
don't shop at whole foods
so the the point of that is if you were
working for 90 000 for a company and
then you go work for yourself for 90 000
you should be taking that money and
buying a secretary buying a receptionist
buying scale buying a sales team
reinvesting money
you should not have any money left over
at 90 grand all of it should be going
to be poured back into the business to
scale out i'll tell you what he said
okay
lebron shows up this dude comes in
15 minutes before practice and lebron
gives him that look like
hey dude what's going on here he's like
what do you mean i'm 15 minutes early
he's like should have been here an hour
ago
and and and when he says that to this
dude
the guy knows lebron's been there for
two hours
so all i ask you to do like here's a guy
probably the best that's ever walked out
on a basketball court
short of michael jordan
but both of them had one thing in common
they worked okay it wasn't about their
just their talent it was about their
work ethic people knew them for their
work ethic so
just ask yourself this week do people
know you for your work ethic
or people are people like man you work
hard
are people actually commenting about you
showing up early and staying late
because if they're not then you're just
you're just blending in with everybody
else's work ethic
at the end of the day talent will not
win the game it is work ethic that will
win the game
so when i saw this i'm like here's a guy
top of his games got all the money you
could possibly
he could never spend all his money
impossible he'll be a billionaire
okay and he's showing up two hours early
to make sure he plays the game to make
sure he's in physical condition
to make sure that he can stay in the
game long past
he doesn't even need it he's got all his
rings i got to tell you i
i was so inspired by because i got a
bunch of partners i got guys that i do
business with i got one of them in
particular that i'm having some problems
with
he told me man if i had your money dude
i would retire
he said it to me over and over and i
hadn't been listening to it enough
to to understand he wants to go lay down
okay
you cannot run what's that thing called
you did all right you can't do an iron
man with that attitude
don't know why you'd want to do an iron
man
but i tell you what if you could do an
iron man and then take that and add it
to your
to your to your career to the the
longevity of your career
you know because look it's going to be
five years from now 10 years from now
it's going to be 20 years you're going
to look back and say
and the marketplace is going to reward
whatever you do every day i'm in a lot
of battles every day that nobody sees i
mean these are some of these battles are
brutal man like
like like there's some things it doesn't
matter how many people you have around
you could have
85 employees another 150 some other
place you could be married have kids
there are so many things that a person
if you're in the game all the way you
will have to do by yourself
you're going to die by yourself like it
doesn't matter how many people you get
around dude there's some things you
gotta you gotta confront your fears by
yourself you gotta confront your doubts
by yourself
like that's the stuff that i'm doing
every day so i'm stringing a lot of
futures i got a lot of games going on
all the time
i got a lot of games i want to win at
half of them i lose
half of my win but i'm going to fight
like like i
i have a tremendous i don't have the
flight
fight or flight i have to fight i'm a
fighter i'm a fighter
like i've really trained the fighter
because i remember being bullied as a
kid and i didn't like it
so you know i'm a fighter i'm in there
figuring out the fight like
all the stuff that i do all the time the
webinar i do one i've done
three webinars in 22 days nobody's done
that nobody's ever done bang bang bang
bang bang
two two or three the third one we sell
like i mean super successful these are
best-selling multi-million dollar
webinars on out of an idea while i'm
doing that i'm negotiating 160 million
dollar sale
125 million dollar refinance
160 million dollar purchase we started
our fourth fund dude just
like for sure how do you do it the more
you guys get going on
the better you're gonna like the game
i'm telling you
you're confused man you want more
activity you want more threats
you don't want less you got slow down
y'all when you slow
down the environment becomes threatening
when you speed up
it becomes your environment this car
right here
this rolls-royce wraith
with magic the magic
astrological zodiac sign built into the
ceiling with little sparkles
something you could ever buy in your
life is a big expensive luxury car
in fact okay in my rant today i want to
share with you
one of the things that i did smart in my
life was i never bought these exotic
cars that everybody seems to go out and
buy as soon as they make a little money
what i did was this i waited i waited
and i waited to ever do a dumb thing
like this dumb one of the dumbest things
ever bought in my damn life
okay i waited until number one
i didn't have to buy one and number two
until it didn't matter
i just got my financial statement in
three months the first three months of
this year compared to last year
a double a double you understand what a
double is
a double means i can do stupid [ __ ] now
okay
look once you make enough money to where
you can blow
461 000 and it don't matter
then go do it okay until then
until then do not waste your money
i'm sorry this car was only 384 thousand
dollars
i didn't want to exaggerate to you but i
think they added some stuff to this bad
boy
so look until then until then
until then don't waste your money on
watches
and cars and and brilliant briony suits
okay it's ridiculous you guys that are
buying 1200
shoes you guys that are buying 200 000
cars you guys that are spending money on
homes
no offense but just you don't need an
expensive house
you don't need a country club yet what
you need is paper
you need money baby you need net worth
you need passive income you need flows
baby flows and flows and flows
you don't need a roll of choice fear is
the great indicator
sooner or later you will experience fear
when you start taking new actions at new
levels
in fact if you aren't then you're
probably not doing enough of the right
things
fear isn't bad or something to be
avoided conversely it's something you
want to seek
and then to embrace fear is actually a
sign that you're doing what is needed
to move in the right direction what is
fear anyway i mean really does it even
exist
is it real i know it feels real when
you're experiencing it but admit it
most of the time what you fear doesn't
even occur
fear for the most part is provoked by
emotions
not rational thinking chances are that
when you were a child you found fear
in irrational things the boogeyman under
the bed for example
adults have their own boogeyman the
unknown rejection
failure fear of success and on and on
for example if you're afraid to call a
client then it's that sign that you
should call that client
fear of speaking with the boss is an
indication you should march into his
office and ask for a moment of his time
everyone everyone experiences fear on
some level
fear doesn't just tell you what to do it
also tells you when to do it
ask yourself what time is it at any
point in the day and the answer is
always the same
the time is now the time is always now
and when you experience
fear it's a sign that the best time to
take action is at that
very moment now the only thing that will
make a difference in that moment of fear
is action failure comes in many forms it
occurs
whether you act or you don't act
regardless of the outcome
i would say it's far preferable to fail
while doing something
than to fail by over preparing while
someone else
walks up and scoops up your dreams fear
is a sign to do whatever it is you fear
and do it quickly i grew up in lake
charles louisiana for those of you don't
know my story and my dad
my dad was he
had five kids wife he was dedicated and
committed to being the provider for his
family like many of you are how many of
you provide for your family
probably want to do a good job at it my
dad wanted to do a good job at it so my
dad died when i was 10 years old he had
he had owned a
life insurance company he actually
started a life insurance company
it was taken from his him and a partner
it was taken from him
at the age of uh i guess he was 42 years
old
42 years old he's got five kids he's got
a wife to take care of and no job how
many been in transition before
yeah so 42 a lot of obligation now
starting to move into the middle class
42 years old he's got
he's got twin boys coming they didn't
plan us
you know good catholic family doing the
planning every five years we'd
they'd have a baby so he was playing you
could tell like when i look back in my
in his life today there's a long answer
to a short question but
like like you guys you guys need to
figure out your your your
why you're going to do whatever you're
going to do my dad knew why he was going
to do what he was going to do but my dad
didn't think big enough
it's it's it's a it's a i i got two
things for my dad one
every day he worked he was up early he
stayed late he's in transition
between 42 and 52 he's in transition in
his life
right he's having to go from life
insurance company big dream
company gets stolen away from him he's
like what am i doing
right this is the story of the middle
class right here this is called gravity
this is uh yesterday's miami bridge
falling
and everybody's like i can't believe
that happened
structures fall folks so this is what i
learned from my dad my mom had to sell a
dream house that was
paid for in cash my dad bought a dream
house a year and a half before he bought
before he died we all went in celebrated
oh my god this is unbelievable this is
crazy this is great we made it to the
middle class
my dad dies my mom has to sell the house
a week
literally a week after my dad dies when
she should have been grieving she was
having to sell this
dream house you understand what i'm
saying this is what i learned when i was
10 years old man life is short
okay my dad didn't provide he did he
worked hard but he didn't have enough
because if he had enough my mom would
not have had to sell the dream house
anybody agree with that
okay my mom did not know how to produce
new income
so my mom had to go into conservation so
when you asked me the question how did
you start
i started with the wrong data okay i
started with the wrong data
and the data was hey life is short
something bad is going to happen all
that's true
but if you could out produce if you
could produce enough
income you could start solving some of
these problems
like indestructible income who do you
work with live with
hang with that's causing you to put a
break
when you accelerate this is a huge issue
okay this is a mental issue totally
mental totally about
who's playing in your park
in your business park who's telling you
oh
by the way it could be somebody you
sleep with could be
it could be the information your kids
are bringing from school it could be
your mom and dad
it could be all those it could be the
paper you're reading the instagram
you're watching the facebook you're
looking at it could be all that
you know you get advice from me and you
and you go flip over to dave ramsey
you're going to see this conflict
like okay grant's using debt dave's not
who's right
so pick somebody and go deep with that
person
if you're going to pick a mentor one of
the biggest questions i get is who
like how do i pick a mentor you already
you got to get rid of mentors you guys
already have too many
you all listen to everybody an open mind
is not always a good thing
when when a parachute when a parachute
opens like this we're good
a wide open mind means this i take
information from anybody and everybody
what you want to do is like this
like you want to run the race with
blinders on
get your data if i have a wrong piece of
data that i'm stable on
i'm probably going to be more effective
than a right piece of data that i'm
unsure about
when i started my business i'd get money
and i'd save it i'd get money and i'd
save i'd get money and i'd save it and i
didn't spend money in marketing and
branding so when i was writing the 10x
rule i'm like
dude why am i not bigger than um i've
been busting my ass working so hard
i've been pushing and shoving i have the
best products of
any anybody in my space i know i have
the biggest
the biggest platform of products and the
best products
why why why are other guys kicking my
ass
and i'm like dude you haven't reinvested
the money in marketing and branding
right i was not spending money i look at
the mattress guy in boston i look at the
car dealer in boston
herb chambers outspent everybody crushes
the the mattress guy
outspends everybody the my the my pillow
guy on on tv
he who knows what he spends he might
spend 100 million dollars a year in
advertising to get a billion dollar and
i'm like oh my god
you didn't market and you didn't
advertise so this month we'll spend
probably a million dollars
on advertising on advertising my whole
life i've been told
be yourself be yourself just be yourself
grant
still today on the second half of my
life
i'm still trying to figure out exactly
what that means to be
myself in fact i would tell you it's
probably bad advice
you have to you have to become someone
else
before you even discover who you really
are i promise you this is true
you're gonna have to
become someone else the real you
you don't know that person yet he's he
he or she's been
overeducated or undereducated
one of the two it's not nothing nothing
you didn't get the perfect amount of
education to actually become who you are
because colleges
and the school systems don't teach you
how to find and discover the real you
i've spent i don't know 30 years of my
life just just stripping away
at the parts of me that aren't me the
poor
louisiana boy the middle class boy the
i gotta save all my money boy the
um you know i gotta i gotta i can't
trust
people stay tight stay close stay small
don't get too big don't get too much
attention i had to strip
all that boy away by the way there's
been hundreds of layers
of false information wrong information
incorrect data
uh uh assumed identities by the way
i wasn't i was operating like a junkie
and an
alcoholic for years told
that alcoholism and drug addiction ran
in my family and i somehow adopted
this just be yourself see if i was still
just being myself whatever
that means i'd still be a junkie
in lake charles louisiana but i'm not
okay i decided to become the me i'm
supposed to be
the the length of time between the idea
and the execution is going to determine
how much money you guys make
get out of maybe stay out of maybe land
if you can get your customer to maybe
that's good you guys need to stay
out of maybe land
maybe land is where doubt lives doubt
slows down the organization
oh god what do i do first time i met
jared jared had been in my office
three or four weeks working first time i
met him i walked up who are you man
i'm jared what are you doing jared i'm
making a list i said dude i don't pay
you to make a list make a call
okay you got an idea to come work for me
pick up the phone and call somebody
because that list will not pay you
the only thing that's going to pay you
is the call right we don't spend enough
time in my company planning
so this is what this is what happens at
our company okay
and i'm not look we don't do everything
right there most of the time this is
what happens
i have an idea
okay i got a guy i got a lot of ideas
how many rooms got a lot of ideas
okay that idea is only as good as you
can monetize that idea
otherwise it's worth nothing the faster
i can monetize this idea the better that
idea is how many agree with that
so i go from idea to monetization we're
going to be going over this later today
this is what you do you go from an idea
to planning
i go with an idea landing page
buy button put a price on it
not even a picture of a product so how
long is it taking you
to go from an idea to monetization and
by the way how many people are involved
there was two people involved we have 85
people at my company i didn't involve
anybody else the more people you
involved if you're taking notes the more
people you
involved the longer it is going to take
to get to a
deliberate a deliverable product i don't
need more ideas
i need execution planning not production
you're spending time
planning thinking ideas buy-in
[Music]
get everybody's input i want everybody
to feel good about it dude i don't care
about any of that
i didn't check with anybody okay i can
be wrong on my own right i don't need i
don't need to spend time
and be wrong let me just get the wrong
as fast as i can
you need you need to go get money like
you don't have to go do a job to get
money
you need to go connect with money like
you need you need to sit down and
understand what kind of money you're
looking for you guys
all of you out there following your
heart and the thing that you're good at
and the thing you love it's costing you
freedom
oh man i'm a good photographer man
that's what i'm gonna do yeah so what
what if it doesn't pay anything
what if you're good at milking cows
ain't nobody paying for milk anymore
but i'm so good at it oh yeah i love it
okay so you're good at you're good
what's that second job you got
uh teaching spanish and english yeah man
it's a hard deal to scale bro like like
you know you're selling time for money
you're trading
time for money yeah so if i were you i'd
go be a nanny to rich people
teach my kids how to speak chinese man
i'll pay i'll pay 50 bucks an hour for
that what are
what are those people paying you oh by
the way i'll give you five hours twice a
week
what do you get for a class right now no
now like here it's more or less like
15 20 yeah exactly because you're doing
it to the wrong public
you need to go to somebody's got a that
that wants to learn and
and and you know you got to figure out
first of all you got to do the
calculation you guys
need to start doing calculations
financial calculations there is nothing
wrong with
follow the money
who's got the money man that's that
t-shirt who's got my damn money
right who can pay you a hundred dollars
an hour bro you're just calling on the
wrong people folks
five grand is a doable deal how do i do
it it's four hundred and twelve dollars
a month
okay i gotta go steal the money i can
steal five thousand you could steal five
grand for me and i wouldn't even know
it's gonna be like
if you could add five thousand to that
and earn twenty percent it'd be worth a
million one twenty five
if you can do this at ten percent it'd
be worth three twenty some of you small
thinkers out there be like dude i'll
take the 320.
how do i get 10 and how do i get 20. you
guys have figured this out you're like
[ __ ]
if the play is big enough dude i'll
figure that out everybody agree see
see what i just i shifted your mind by
giving you a target
i don't go to target i get targets and i
keep targets and i refresh the target
and the target is i want to be a
millionaire but over the period of time
i got 20 years by the way
what would pay me 20 a year
over 20 years and that
is when your boy gc got rich
i didn't get rich speaking i didn't get
rich selling books
[Music]
i got rich shopping real estate 30 years
old
shopping every weekend dude every
weekend all i did between 25 and 30
years old was make money make money make
money and push it aside push it aside
push it aside
even when in the first years when i was
not watch this
even when i was not 25 years old
five grand boom next year five grand
boom next year five grand boom
guess what next year oh by the way this
money's sitting dead in the bank
it's not not only anything it's it's in
a it's in a holy
account holy means
okay i'ma put a hole in your face if you
touch my money
nobody could get this money this is a
like sacred account okay you with me
28 oh wow man i could add a little bit
maybe there's more money
29. what am i doing right here okay
one two three four boom i got 25 000
sitting in an account
it wasn't a million dollars and i'm five
years into the plan
but when i was ready to start investing
money
i started doing my homework 30 years old
homework shopping properties 31
homework shopping properties 32. i'm not
buying cars
you guys are buying cars flying on jet
charters showing off going on vacations
all i'm doing is stacking paper
guess what happens i have five years of
putting five grand away
next thing you know i had twenty five
thousand dollars to add to my twenty
five thousand dollars
next year i'm making more money i got
twenty five thousand dollars you see
what i'm doing i'm stacking dough
and looking for twenty percent
i know there's a 20 play out there some
of this money was sitting in the bank
this is years and years ago where the
bank would pay me six or seven or eight
it didn't matter that's not the target
the target is to get to one million
remember this and let's open up the
calls okay your job is to find a vehicle
that can pay you 20
a year might be a business might be the
business you're in it might be to buy
advertising for the business or brand
you're in
for me it was this i'm gonna buy real
estate
that over long periods of time i will
earn
cash flow okay that's how the real
estate works
i put 25 000 in a deal
that deal is probably going to pay me 10
a year
you said yeah but grant you said what'd
you say grant would you say
20 grand that's what you said yeah i
know what i said
this ain't eddie okay now how much do i
have
i could reinvest that money back in the
deal the next year i have twenty seven
thousand five hundred dollars
[Music]
i earned ten percent on that that's
27.50 or something like that
i reinvest that now i got 30 000 in the
deal
okay but what you don't know is the the
rent on this property
as i own it over 20 years 2038 we'll
dispose of this thing the rent is going
up
as i'm adding money the rent's going up
and maybe this goes from 10
a year by the time i sell i want to be
at 20
okay my average deal has paid me over 30
a year so when you start taking money
and start compounding it like that
for long periods of time the trick is
long periods of time
if you study the most successful people
that you know in any business the warren
buffets
in finance the lebron james and
basketball you just start studying i've
been studying since i was
since my dad died my dad died when i was
10 years old and i needed
mentors and you can't go get another dad
my uncles they weren't that they had
their own life going on so they they
couldn't mentor me
so i was like well who are these people
we we all have examples
the problem today in america is the
example
it's getting more and more average it's
we're becoming an epidemic of mediocrity
so
if you study the really really you know
exuberantly successful people
they're going to have some traits in
common obsessed
if you've ever met a great sales manager
great sales person
great used car manager great finance
manager they're obsessed
they read study learn eat it you know
they're obsessed people
see obsession in our culture though is
not a good thing
if you when you hear the word obsession
you start thinking a guy's got a problem
obsessive compulsive disorder look if
you're not getting labeled
if people are not labeling you in
society as a freak case
then you're not successful whatever goal
you want let's say you have a financial
goal even though that's just one goal
you know you'd have life spiritual your
family
your marriage how much action do you
need to take
if you want to become a millionaire
number one you have to decide to become
a multi-millionaire you're going to
miscalculate the zeros
and this is what the 10x rule was the
10x rule was a multiplier you must
multiply
in order to add you have to learn how to
do something a lot of times to ever get
good at it
for sabrina to be good at what are those
things you do cartwheels
she's going to do thousands tens of
thousands of cartwheels
to finally be able to stay on one line
same thing for the ballerina
same thing for lebron i have to do
something 10 000 times
before i'll ever make a billion dollars
or 100 million
or 10 million you got to get great at it
folks frequency is the way to greatness
number one
decide to become a multi-millionaire not
a millionaire one
go for multi-millionaire status go for
the multi-status
okay if you want 10 if you want one go
for 10 if you want 10 go for 100
decide on a multiple fail high rather
than
setting a target that later you find out
was too low
stop all poverty behavior poverty
is a terrible thing if you've ever known
anybody lived in poverty
suffer with poverty even close to the
poverty line you know
that it is awful and even those with
money
can live like they are in poverty i've
known millionaires that acted like they
were in poverty
wouldn't spend any of the money they had
because they were worried about money
not coming in in the future
make a list of all the actions because
most of this is mental
make a list of all action those who live
in poverty
operate with and commit to not doing
them listen what i'm saying here make a
list
of the activities that people that
either live in poverty
or act like they're living in poverty
how they operate every day
drugs alcohol buying stuff not investing
but spending waste in weekends
government or any kind of dependence
upon others
shortcuts victim mentality not reading
refusing to network
and refusing to get outside your zip
code and travel
are all things that you need to stop and
i'm sure you can expand this list
stop all poverty behavior so i have 12
employees i'm sure at one point you had
you know four or five employees
how did you go from four or five to
whatever you have
i had two employees from the age of
[Music]
29 no from the age of 30 to
38 years old i had two employees
for eight years i did everything i was
the secretary
phone answer uh i did payroll
stole for myself did my taxes i did my
own taxes i wouldn't pay anybody
anything
okay from uh 30 to
38 38 to 45 i added like two or three
people
i was i was officing out of the guest
house
at my my my place that i lived at in in
los angeles
it's a big guest house it was a dude it
was an awesome hour lionel richie lived
in that house
you know it was a cool house
right but it was small thinking man i
was still thinking little
[Music]
and if you're going to stay small you're
going to get crushed so i'll push you
over the edge
2009 2008 and 2009.
so what eventually made you say you know
what i'm just going to make a freeway
what happened was a guy told me years
before that
that bigger's not better and i believed
it
because he busted out he busted out when
he went big
and he says grant bigger's not better
man stay small and i
and i believed that dude and i carried
it on a long time it's bad advice
knowledge is power bad knowledge is too
so what i did was i stayed small until i
was 45 years old
five employees i was one of them so four
and um when 2008 came i'm like this was
dude like i got a scale and and that was
what 12 uh how many years ago was that
nine years
seven or eight years ago there was no
jet
there was no big office it just shows
you man when you change your mind when
you change your mind and start like
hey i'm gonna scale this thing out i'm
gonna go global i'm gonna have people
know me i'm gonna get attention
i'm gonna get my products out i'm gonna
lower my prices i'm gonna bring this
thing to market i'm to get big bring in
good people
we have how many employees we have now
charity 72 at the office
we got our partners here tonight we got
another 150 in uh
in in the real estate game we're going
to expand that we'll probably pick up
another 12 or 15 this month
because the two more deals we're
bringing on and next year i'm talking
about going global so
all everything that happened everything
has happened really good to us
it's happened because of the expansion
when i'm in a deal and the problem's
there i will i will nag
on it and create some drama there's a
problem there's a problem there's a
problem
but i'm like okay what are we going to
do about it like i want to get to the
solution now let's drop it i don't even
harbor
harbor one of the biggest deals in my
whole life and this guy promised to do
one thing then found out he couldn't
and i want to punch him in the face i
want to i want to punish him for it i
want him to
like i want to crucify him a bit over it
right and then i'm like
i even want to tell him i'm not going to
do the deal even though i know the deal
is good for me right and then i'm like i
got to put that up
do the deal that's the solution let's
move on no i think that
what i've done is i've basically taken
the things that
bother me and turn them around like
you know um i didn't have an uncle
so i'm like hey why don't you quit
saying how you didn't have an
uncle and be the uncle that's so good i
hated the car business so i'm like
rather than quitting the car business
and walking away from it why don't you
make the car business better so uh i
don't like the way little
little people are treated with their
finances how the banks treat you the
401ks
buying a house all the scams so i'm like
you know what i can't just [ __ ] about
something
without becoming part of the solution so
that's why absolutely sure
that's why we created cardone capital i
was 51 years old between the age of 25
and 51 i didn't have one drink
i said until i get my money so right i
don't deserve a hangover
i'm not having any more hangovers those
hangovers cost you money
right how many of you woke up with a
hangover today paid attention to it for
the first two hours
how good you feel man how good you feel
how confident you are it takes a lot of
confidence to go get money it takes a
lot of willingness and determination you
know
it's not a problem when you're broke
it's a problem when you get money when
you start having a little bit of money
that's when most people soften up would
you agree
how often do i look at my finances every
day man i say send me that if you got
one checking account with three thousand
dollars in it
look at it if you don't look at it
if you ignore it it will go away
money loves attention money's like a
it's like a jealous lover you don't pay
attention to it you're gonna find
somebody else to bed with
create multiple flows of income it is
said that the average millionaire
has seven flows of income that's not
true
i assure you the rich boys and girls
have many many more flows than seven i
probably have closer to 700
than i do uh seven multiple flows
never rely on one flow of anything okay
and by the way
those of you out there quitting your job
you're like i'm not
you didn't quit your job you left your
job you started network marketing
and you gave the network marketing more
attention than your first job now you're
back to one job again
okay the reason you got a network
marketing was to get two flows of income
going
don't leave the first one go to the
second one abandon the first one you end
up with one again multiply
iron people is not the problem getting
rid of them is that's the
flat okay and i don't care if we get rid
of them
like you're like i don't remember any of
them
i tell my wife all the time they might
all go
[Music]
see we might just nuke them because
we're going to go win the game
so you guys going to help me win the
game we're going to win the game
together you're not going to help me win
the game
you won't be in a stadium and that's the
way it is brothers sisters uncles aunts
i like you i love you
we spooned it once whatever dude if
you're not helping us move the ball down
the field you're gonna go
dads uncles aunts brothers
sisters mothers cousins bro look you're
not helping anymore
bye-bye good for everybody
right if you've ever drugged somebody
along and they weren't in the game
anymore
when you let them go they're happy about
it later they're pissed off in the
beginning and then they're like
man thanks a lot man i wasn't shipping
it anymore was i
so i know i can see that some of you are
thinking right now man i got to get
even your friends dude you're already a
company everybody here already has a
company
you are a company right now you don't
get a company you are a company
all the friends you got the leeches the
losers
right the bad advice givers all the
books that you put up with every day
all the bad advice you get all the
freaking stealing going on around you
the person that works across
the desk from you that steals hours from
your owner
that talks negative about your owner the
guy that's writing them a check
and he's like hey what a what a wanker
he is right and you listen all that all
that's affecting you that is your
company right now
never lose
money
period when i invest in a relationship
and i take a client to dinner i cannot
lose that money the money goes away from
me
and i get the relationship they remember
i remember
right when i put damon john on my plane
and fly him across las vegas
it would appear that i lost money damon
remembers i remember we
talk about it and it pays me in the
future never lose money
okay i get on a plane fly across the
country my wife and i
and the kids and we fly over there and
we have great memories that money is
lost
don't kid yourself oh got great memories
of my kids you should have brought
somebody with you think bigger
what you ought to do is bring a family
that could do business with you that
could advance your network
you would be better off spending 10
times more money than less money
and having an investment never lose
money
quit investing in stocks quit
speculating quit bitcoining
i mean until you're rich don't play that
game i'm 19 years old
and i run a consulting firm and right
now i i just tell you real estate stuff
and i have
only about 60 grand from what i've done
saved up yeah and do you think i need to
still wait until a hundred grand if you
pass the real estate or yeah
how long you had 60 grand uh for just
like 12 months now yeah dude like you
got to get the other 40 bro
it's an arbitrary number i just made up
the number it could be 110 it could be
dude it's just it's just so you know
first of all when you get to 100 call me
and i'm gonna probably tell you hey man
you need to wait till you got 350.
but at least then you're gonna be like
you know what i i learned how to make i
learned how to not just make a hundred
save a hundred and put a hundred away
people are investing too
soon you guys are investing three grand
here two grand over here a thousand
bucks
500 you're walking away from it it's
never worth any money it's dumb
and you never create the discipline what
you end up with is a bunch of losses a
bunch of little losses
rather than knowing i have the
confidence that i can make money
set it aside protect it
right protect it like a kid
[Music]
right it's not going to get in a wreck i
don't lose it
i would do that first was there an age
i didn't invest my my first investment
was five thousand dollars and i blew it
and i'm like i'm not doing that again my
next investment is going to be big
where i'm going to watch it because if
it's big enough dude if your life
depends on it you'll get up in the
mornings and you'll watch it
so my next deal was 350 grand it took
three years to do it
all i did was save money save money save
money i put 350 grand in the deal
sold that deal for 4 million a 4 million
profit penny you had
i had i had one third of all my money in
that deal i had a million dollars
like a million one put 350 in my first
deal
30 days later put 450 in a second deal
90 days later put
all the rest of my capital 100 of all my
money
plus 90 grand in three real estate deals
those are the first three investments i
ever made my the first
three or four investments i made in my
entire life
three of the four did the little one
didn't
[Music]
the little one couldn't work
it's impossible to work it was too small
what's it gonna do
it's not going to do anything
it's like going into a casino and you
bet 15
right you get blackjack so what it's
still 15
the first thing you're going to say is
dude i should have bet everything
but you didn't shouldn't even be in
there
look behind a jet was something i never
dreamed i'd do
i never okay i only started thinking
about it four or five years ago
when i'm young and broke and growing up
in louisiana middle class being told
be grateful you got to bite on a bike be
grateful you got clothes on your back
and you get three meals be grateful for
all that you got cause you got it better
than i do i never dreamed of having my
own damn chest
whatever you have to do to keep your
purpose burning
hot you do it you borrow money okay
use money if it requires money so be it
if you're truly obsessed it will be
worth it because you will get the
results
you know the secret to sustaining the
obsession is a straightforward one
focus your efforts on everything that
will fuel you
for the long run and ignore eliminate
and block out anything
that drains you or causes you doubt
money
power fame success all all of them
follow attention
so what gets the most attention is what
will grow
the problem with these things is money
power fame and success even time off
they require attention they're like
jealous lovers they need
constant attention or they're gonna
leave you how you invest your time is
more important than how you invest your
money
being obsessed with your sense of
purpose across every part of your life
will allow you to accomplish
all the things you desire i think most
people are not accomplishing what they
want in one area of life
because they quit on all the other ones
if you quit on all the other ones how
are you going to get this one to run
nothing inspires me more than
surrounding myself with people
who have achieved more than i have and
then meeting new people
i need the obsessed must surround
themselves with
people you trust and respect who think
big who've done bigger than you
and who can help you get to where you
want to go you think you can run
only so fast time is no longer an excuse
look man if you can't get your money
right something's wrong
if you can't take care of your family
you got to ask yourself how much of a
man are you
like for me that identifies me as a man
my ability to take care of my family
i don't just mean financially but i do
mean financially
right my job as a as head of household
is to take care of the economics of the
household you know the word economy if
you look it up in the dictionary it
comes from
managing a household it had nothing to
do with the business
it was about managing the household so
if you go back a thousand years we've
been managing households
my job as a man is to provide a place
where it's warm
a place where we can sleep a place where
we're protected a place where there's
food
right not money right i need to be able
to take care of the family shelter
food clothing and i need to have some
fun my family wants to have fun we want
to have experiences so
i need to provide a secure environment
for them so they're not
think bad things aren't just happening
and so so men need to like bone up
man like the government can't take care
of you bone up you know this
yeah bone up get strong right so get a
get a backbone
and take care of your family and quit
blaming the government
or making excuses that your neighbor
or the economy or whatever
conditions look i have i've had some
terrible conditions in my life
uh from the age of uh 15 till
25 it was awful for me 10 years nobody
would want to go through the 10 years
that i went through do some people have
it worse than i did probably
but i don't want to do those 10 those 10
years were
terrible for me as degrading as a human
being can experience
drugs yeah drugs but mostly just
so many bad choices so many bad people
you know
so so much self uh self uh
deprivation and and just a lack of self
esteem and self love
for myself because of a lot of bad
choices
so i understand what goes on to for a
person when they're making bad choices
and
and and people just need to man up you
know
bone up the women need to do the same
thing by the way yeah women are stronger
than men today
look i hate pain any kind of pain women
can handle 10 times the pain i can
handle
my job is to get 8 billion people to
know me if enough people know me they'll
buy from me how many believe that
i'm not going to be i'm not going to be
a slave to one person or one vertical or
one niche or one partnership
i have you guys have the whole world at
your access
the whole world and by the way if you
can't get south korea to talk about you
you can't get south indiana or
indianapolis to talk about you
there's people in korea that are tied to
hawaii that are tied to colombia
that know somebody in indiana and it can
just bang out like that
and i also believe that if i could get
enough people to know me in one market
i think that there's something that
actually happens
i think if you could outf if you could
get if you could push out enough
frequency about your brand yourself your
ideas to enough people that you hit some
critical mass
i don't know if any of you agree with
this but i think there's a spiritual
component
to where if you can vibrate through
enough all of a sudden
other people start thinking i know that
dude
i've said this for years if i can get
enough people a very small
percentage of the population know me i
think the other 99
become convinced they know me do you
think that somebody
needs to reach a certain like status
before but no
no no you do not need to reach certain
status you need to assume the status now
you need to have the altitude right now
to be the professional that says hey i
know about fitness
i know about plumbing i know about
trucks just take whatever you guys are
certain about and post it out of it and
by the way if you're not certain about
it
write an article about what your
uncertainties costing you you're going
to figure out
every possible angle but none of that's
going to happen until you guys make a
decision to blow up
and none of the blow up shit's going to
happen until you make a decision that
money is important because if you've got
people around you saying money's not
important ain't no way you're gonna do
this stuff
because it hurts when nobody sees your
stuff
study two multi-millionaires do not
take heed to this do not study a
millionaire once a person becomes a
millionaire the first thing they do
unfortunately is go into conservation to
protect the million
study multi-millionaires study people
that have consistently
developed and proven because the tens or
twenties or thirties or hundreds of
millions of dollars
that they've accumulated that they have
the right practice the right
discipline and they're still expanding
you don't need 22 mentors
study two people deep that have gotten
it right
study two people so deep rather than 20
people shallow i promise you'll make a
difference
if you get a chance to spend three days
with anybody that's accumulated 30 40
50 100 million dollars i'll promise you
it's a game changer so put that on your
bucket list
i'm gonna spend three days with a
multi-millionaire in an environment
where i can learn from them
it will be a game changer for you and
also limit your study to two people
not 22 people that will create you from
having conflictive
uh data and content and information
nobody's ever done it by themselves
so the old the the entrepreneur that's
uh popular right now is the guy that
works from home
he's a solopreneur um i don't know if
you have this term
we have yeah yeah it's a complete
misnomer
nobody has ever existed on this planet
and done something successful by
themselves
no it's never happened so there's no
there's zero examples of anybody that's
done any i mean jesus
had had 12 of course had 12 guys he was
rolling with
right alexander the great had an army uh
genghis khan
had had like you're not doing this thing
by yourself nobody does
we're a team like like for too long i
ran by myself
and and it took a lot of energy you know
it took a lot of energy it takes more
energy running by yourself
uh ryan secco here the captain the pilot
and and the real estate dude he always
says
dude it's just more fun to run with the
team and he's right yeah you know
henry ford people said henry ford made
the car out of his garage
i said yeah but the company didn't make
they didn't make
to the yeah yeah so uh mark zuckerberg
said you know facebook was made out of a
dorm facebook was made when he moved to
silicon valley
and started a company uh steve jobs
steve and
and the the the other dude what was it
dude yeah yeah
they built apple you know supposedly
built it out of their garage
yeah no nobody knew about apple until he
moved the company
and started and and added employees so
nobody's doing anything great by
themselves
you guys would take days off it's my day
off you ain't entitled to a day off
why do you think you should have
wednesdays off or thursdays or you can't
work
saturdays or sunday sunday you can't
work on a sunday
okay are you and you got people around
you telling you not to work on sunday
we have to have a little life balance
dude how can you have life balance when
you broke
how can you have life balance at a
holiday inn when the people next door
keep you up all night
that ain't life balance that's not even
a vacation
right the whole trip how many have been
on the trip you did the budget trip
included the free breakfast you did it
on miles
and you wish you didn't even go how many
been on that trip before
maybe you don't do the trip maybe you're
not entitled to a trip this year maybe
you're not ready to trip
[Music]
that's what elena and i did for 10 years
the sacrifice
the sacrifice today we'll sacrifice this
week we'll sacrifice this month we'll
sacrifice
this year we'll sacrifice so one day
maybe
we don't have to compromise every week
we talk about our finances what do we do
this week how much do we make
where are we going what are we spending
okay the moment i say hey no more
jackets no more
stop it she'll stop it so that we can
one day
we can one day spend whatever we want
okay there
there there is should come a time where
you guys should be able to spend
whatever you want but most people are
spending what they can afford
now only to find out later they can
never have anything
they don't understand how to make their
money multiply and most people don't
understand
there is a sacrifice phase yeah we went
through the sacrifice phase where there
was
years of just cut off everything and we
weren't saving for a landing
for the rainbow that's right y'all need
to save for the rainbow you need it you
see
we didn't go on a vacation for 13 years
yeah
i've been saving for this stuff i wasn't
saving for vacations i was saving so i
could bank into real estate
so i could go to sleep at night and even
if i had a bad night of sleep and had to
get up three or four times
i'm like dang i'm making money in my
sleep even if i'm unhappy i'm like i'm
making money in my sleep man
see that's the goal that you and your
wife need to have let's make money when
we go to turks and caicos or when we go
to st
bart's or when we go to cali let's go
waste some money later in our life
maybe you say hey i'm going to sacrifice
today
so i don't have to compromise in the
future hey man
i'm 20 years old and contracting here in
michigan
um my biggest question is you uh
gain credibility in business being young
in an industry
yeah so good question i'm glad you said
new to the industry not because you're
only 20 years old
you got it you got to get you got to
become you got to become the uh the
expert buddy i don't i don't know how to
tell you this any other way you got to
become
you got to become the expert in the room
you got to know more than everybody else
you got to be
like people say oh if you're in if
you're in a room and you're the smartest
guy in the room you're in the wrong room
you go in a room dude you need to be the
smartest guy in the room
you need to be the guy in the room that
sucks the oxygen out of the room
so elon elon musk walks in a room and
everybody's like going
up to the office but doing my best just
trying to build rapport
and uh no don't don't don't try to build
report dude you got you got to become an
expert at your deal like if you're
milking cows you need to become the
freaking guy that knows every freaking
angle on a on a on a cow's
titty okay
like michigan right
gosh okay so dude take take like
like you're 20 years old bro spend the
next four or five years becoming an
expert in your field
study it breathe it live in it don't
drink the kool-aid
do backstrokes in it i don't do
businesses that don't
serve my life so the real estate
it's just what i'm doing every day right
it's the speaking
it it just all fits for me so
i need a lot of action but they all work
like like my hand i move my pinky and
all the other fingers removed
so if i move this business it it touches
these businesses the businesses are all
connected they're interconnected
they're a bit connected right so if i
move one we came here to do a speaking
gig
okay but we stacked this interview
this is part of my business right my our
online presence
is dependent upon me being willing to do
this
in addition we don't go anyplace for one
thing
so the guy that tells you focus on one
business
why don't we have one finger why don't i
just have one thing
great right so boom i got i got noticed
i got five fingers and i got two hands
i had a i had a girlfriend but this was
before i was married she says you want
your cake and you want to eat it too and
i said yeah
why have a cake if you can't eat it okay
so my my mom used to tell me you need to
focus on one thing at a time i'm like
five fingers five feet two hands okay
so i want my hands and all a bunch of
pies
i just want to be sure i want to eat
that pie okay i want to eat that meal
right because i think a lot of people
have their hands
sorry i think a lot of people have their
hands and stuff they don't really want
to eat the meal
do you guys just rubberneck your whole
life you know you ever been driving down
the road there's a wreck on the side and
everybody's like
oh my god why is all the traffic stopped
there's only one person with a flat tire
on the side of the road
right everybody's stopping to see what
happened over there
you rub a neck in your life and not
getting where you want to go okay
because everything's a distraction
some people call it schizophrenia like
my friend kathleen
but it's not really schizophrenia it's a
lack of focus
make hard decisions fast people say
man you're a hard man you're a tough
dude okay
look you got to make hard decisions fast
when things get
tough they say the tough get going truth
is when things get tough
the successful make hard decisions
quickly that's why super successful
people are often misunderstood they're
willing to make
hard decisions that often don't make
them look good
and for which they're later judged the
truth is for you to be
financially successful you will have to
make very very difficult decisions when
you do
make them fast my mom used to say if
you're walking through the sun
pick it up go fast i want you to walk
away
understanding that some of you have
businesses that are just
not good businesses and if you have a
business that's no good
you can't build the empire you want why
do i need money what don't i know about
money why are people struggling with
money you should ask yourself these
questions
why are you coming up short on money
[Music]
is it what you know or what you don't
know
how many of you know this saying
knowledge is
okay how many of you agree with that how
many agree knowledge is power
so look if you don't have money and you
have knowledge maybe you have the wrong
knowledge
i've been here five years you guys don't
know me you know why
i didn't let you know me if you don't
know me
you won't flow me right or wrong so my
job is to make sure i'm known today
today it's easier than it's ever been
before that's why i'm a guy that's using
social media to get known it takes
courage to stand up here
it takes courage to get known it takes
courage to build a brand
it takes courage to build a youtube
channel and an instagram and a facebook
i'm 60 years old
i don't know anything about instagram
except that i got 900
000 people that follow me every day like
a religion
you ask what church do you go to i go to
the church of grant
codon okay what's my name
my name is grant cardone what's my name
my name cause you didn't know this is
for the people that didn't know my name
is grant cardone let me hear it
okay my job my job my first job your
first job is to make sure people know
your
name because if they don't know your
name they i don't care what you sell
you're a nurse you work at mcdonald's
you're a bellman i don't care what you
do
you're parking cars it don't matter if i
don't know who you are
it doesn't matter how good you are how
clean you are
okay it doesn't matter your values don't
matter nothing matters if i don't know
you
so i don't believe in this concept about
balancing business in life
i've never all the people that talk
about it don't have don't have the very
thing they're trying to get probably
yeah
so you're constantly balancing something
you're under stress that i think so
totally totally so so if you just like
what i do is i just push into everything
right i push into everything as hard as
i can
and and again the goal is life it's not
the business
it's my life right business is part of
my life
so having fun is part of my life my
spiritual part is part of my life so i'm
going to push
everything into that thing that i'm
working on the 10x
the 10x thing was about i'm pushing like
if
if it's if it's in the business i'm
going to push as hard as i can on that
and my kids are with me my wife's with
me she they're with me so they're
they're having the experience of this
push then we turn around we push over
here oh we want to help charities out
and we push 10x into that direction
well it's just it just blows out the
edges
of the life right so that we get to have
a bigger experience
as opposed to okay now i need to put
this here
and manage this part right now which
means when i'm doing this
when i'm finding time just for my kids
i'm abandoning all these other things
and my life gets smaller all the
commitment stuff oh you got to be
committed oh you got to be committed we
always talking to my trainer about this
you got to be committed treat this
there's only one thing you really have
to do
because the commitment's not going to
come until you do this other thing
the thing that has got me through
everything
got me to where i'm at today the thing
that changed everything
was me just taking action just doing it
i mean i know that's that old nike
saying right just do it
man even if you don't feel like it even
if you're not committed even if you're
not getting any gains
even if you're not winning talk about
this in the rules of success
show up just take action make the call
knock on the door
send out the email bug people if you
have to
you know until you get good and and it
doesn't sound like bugging anymore
it's just the professional knows how to
bug people without bugging them
so look just take action money is so
simple
okay anybody got a 100 bill
give me a hundred dollars sir give this
man a big hand for having some money
okay i just had an idea i said i wonder
i ain't got any money on me i had an
idea now i'm gonna teach you a lesson
right now that'll make you rich if you
can get it okay number one
i want some money
number two i need to ask somebody if
they got 100.
number three i need to get the money
it's no more complicated than that
i didn't go manufacture something i
didn't build a business plan
i didn't create a product i had an idea
the the length of time between your idea
and the money will determine whether or
not you're successful
the length of time between the idea
and the monetization big word for
get the money the
the distance between the idea and the
money
will determine whether you take off or
not why do we make so many excuses i
think that we are like
excuses making machines yeah yeah
yeah like if i miss a deal we we do a
lot of real estate deals so if i miss a
deal
i'm always going to what did i do wrong
in that deal first response for me is
what did i do wrong in that deal that
they didn't pick me
what did i do wrong that i didn't get
that deal what did we do wrong
that we didn't hit our number there like
i'm never saying
it's not blaming somebody well i don't
have control when i blame
i want control so even if they are to
blame
right i want control i'm not going to
assign you blame
if you hit my car i'm gonna say what did
i do wrong
what did i do that allowed you to hit my
car
i did something so even in the most
like i i ended up in a lawsuit where a
guy basically
found something sued me for it
i didn't do anything to this dude my
immediate response was what did i do to
create that
frivolous situation he was a criminal
total criminal
sued me for 60 million bucks he just
sued me because he
he thought he could get something from
it but but i did something
and the reason i want to assume that
what the cause i want to be the cause
point is because if i assume
that position even though i didn't
really do anything
then i can control what i did i can't
control what another person does but i
can spend time and energy controlling
what i do
the company is only as great as the
driver is number two
does the dude have a bunch of fuel you
know what fuel is see this plane right
here this plane's no good
no matter how good this plane is if
there's no fuel
play no good plane don't go any place
without fuel neither does a company
i know guys that have great companies
but they're out of fuel they're just not
they're not going to use it they're
drivers they were drivers
they used to drive they got fuel in a
tank but
three they won't use it they're not
going to press because somebody's
on their neck right now saying conserve
your money a lot of rich people this
happens to a lot of rich people
people get rich they go from the middle
to rich and never get wealthy
and with the wealthy it becomes
impossible to get wealthy like the
rockefellers
or the people that we're talking about
the duponts the morgans the uh
who the vanderbilts because because the
car down
the car don'ts because they get
satisfied with wealthy
i'm sorry with rich and they never get
wealthy wealthy is
generational money grant died i
guarantee you my grandkids will be
talking about me that's a bam
right there dude that dude that dude
that dude god damn okay
and then number four dude you got to
have a future like the future i'm
interested in and
and by the way i'm gonna go back to the
new world order boys and girls
the the illuminati the masons whoever
they are
these people think about futures you
guys don't they're thinking about
generations that's what the japanese do
the japanese
they think about future generations
they're not thinking about right now
how about the muslims they're thinking
about lifetimes from now
how many heard this before people buy
from people they like
no no no people buy from people they
know okay if you're taking notes
people buy from people they know period
they don't buy the best product they
don't buy the cheapest product people
buy
from people they know because if you
don't know me
trust will not happen that's why i
rolled up on damon and said hey how
about i put you in the plane
and i fly you to fight to vegas same
dude's telling me i was stupid behind a
plane
i said dude come on what's wrong with
you man
you spent too much time on a street
corner selling hats
that bird that bird that bird is what
got me in front of you dj
little man oh yeah yeah you're right man
and then he says
now i'd have gone with you anyway you
would not have got on jetblue with me
don't lie man i know you're the people
shark but don't lie
what am i call you up hey damon i bought
a ticket for us on southwest
you want to fly to vegas with me and we
can eat peanuts
he wouldn't have gone with me how many
agree he would not have gone with me
come on man he might be the people's job
but he ain't stupid
he's like hey i ain't doing that right
or wrong
he said to me what's the fuel in that
jet cost
i said bro you you're thinking small bro
he's like what do you mean what's it
cost what's the damn fuel in the jet
cost
i said i don't know why don't you know i
said because
the jet ain't no good without fuel
i think the the idea of
knocking on doors you know talking to
people yeah like these are the skills
that are not taught in the schools this
is what goes back to your question about
the school system failing
debate the the the required skills
i need a client like if you simplify the
thing that people like about what we do
is we
simplify the business process i need to
make a contact
how can i do that like how can i just
simply
if i'm doing if i'm a cameraman and i
want more work
you know how do i knock on a door or
make a phone call get in front of
someone
it's so hard impress them you know if i
go to heron's right here i'll see how
many people don't have that skill
i walk in they i don't even get hello
you know i don't get hello how you doing
great to have you here appreciate you
being here it's so nice for you to drop
by
thanks for coming into cartier i mean
it's a three million dollar ring over
there i went in there the other day i
can't even get anybody to show me
anything
i'm like how much is the ring you know
they kind of look at me right can you
show it to me do you mind showing it to
me
he showed it to me told me how much it
was and i leave you didn't show me a
second ring a third ring or fourth ring
so those are the skills that people need
right how do i
how do i interact with people
communicate yeah
the middle class adds and subtracts
and and clearly the middle class never
figured out
how to do what the super wealthy do like
it's almost like
hundreds of millions of people in
america stopped math at adding and
subtracting and never got to the
multiplication part
because the super wealthy are
multipliers oh by the way time
energy and money they multiply all of
them they're like like i have time i
want to make more time
how do i do that you learned how to add
you learned how to subtract but that's
not what the ross challenge did that's
not what the rockefellers did that's not
what the duponts did
they multipliers we can't afford that
how many you told your kids about that
before we can't do that bike
we can't buy the bike right you told
your kids that because you were told
that
right we don't tell our kids that how
many of you have told us kids be careful
that's why you guys think so much you
got you got dave ramsey on tv saying
total freedom comes from
not having debt okay you got you
you flip channels and you go to susie
you can't afford that
okay i'm going to tell you do you can
afford anything
no no hey debt's not your problem okay i
got
four four i got i probably got 500
million dollars worth of debt today
500 million i was 28 years old
three years sober no drugs in my body
for three years
i'm selling cars i'm moving toyotas
and i'm getting good at it too like you
come in and say look i got bad credit
and i'm not buying today i'm like oh sh
that's two cars
[Music]
i'm gonna penalize i'm gonna penalize
you for saying that boy
okay okay yeah man you got bad credit
that's perfect at least you got some
credit
see i ain't positive i'm there to get
something so so captain ryan says to me
he's like you're the most positive
person i know i said dude i'm not
positive at all
i'm 10x i get results
okay i want to get the deal done
i want to make my kids proud of me
my kids aren't going to remember whether
i was positive or not they're going to
remember whether daddy delivered the
goodies or not
you understand when you go to whole
foods and they say hey that'll be 427
for three bags
and you're like i got a good attitude
they'd be like you need to get some 10x
you need to get some 10x and some money
to go with your
attitude all the greats on this planet
were addicted to something jesus was
addicted
he's like hey man i'm gonna do whatever
it takes
right or wrong okay you gotta get
addicted to something
good all addictions are not created
equal
okay i'm addicted to my wife
i'm addicted to my kids i'm addicted to
my purpose
i'm addicted to helping out i'm addicted
to making a difference
i'm addicted to doing whatever it takes
to show and be an example of the
blessings that i have
one of the things that we do a little
trick we do at our company
is we always have something on our
calendar to look forward to okay if you
want to stay motivated
today's what sunday i always have
something out here
out here out here out here and out here
to look forward to
little short runways that keep me
excited okay
i'm going to turks and caicos to shoot a
real estate uh program when i leave here
yesterday i walked out of here i'm
exhausted i'm like boy i can't wait to
get to turks and caicos
see it re-energizes me right
now when i'm done with that i need
something else to look forward to here i
got a whole
bunch of stuff that's going to happen
here at the end of the month that is
going to keep me
jacked up when i'm at turks and caicos
because the truth is turks and caicos
could get a little boring
for a guy like me how many of you have
trouble
going on vacations you have trouble
unwinding
okay you don't even want to go you're
like i can't even enjoy this
so i need little tricks i have little
tricks everybody should do this in their
life okay
you need things to look forward to the
world you
live in today the cnbc and the cnn and
the netflix
[Music]
be happy just be happy
be satisfied with what you have there's
no push man there's nobody pushing you
how about this you can do more how many
of you can do more
oh my god if that's all you got how many
of you can do more
oh god damn if you know you can do more
if you
know you can do more then you have to do
more
if you know you can help if you know you
can make a difference
if you don't you're going to have this
freaking
big big hole inside of no no amount of
money can fill this thing up
for 30 years since i left that treatment
center i have been doing one thing
studying business i don't need to worry
about my neighbor
i don't need to worry about trump i
don't need to worry about obama
i don't need to worry about the
democrats i don't need to worry about
anything
until i worry about these 36 inches
man man people like hey do you believe
in aliens dude i got
i'm having trouble with this
all i'm trying to do is expand it over
to here
once i do that maybe i can expand a
little bit but i got to get those
six feet under control
i don't criticize other people i'm too
busy criticizing me
while i work on my life i hope other
people hate on me and criticize me i
love it
it's fuel man i'm like then come on
bring it on
commit to getting more done the more you
get done the more you
will earn why do i get more done because
i post
i post without looking at it i simply
get more done why
because i'm committed to getting more
done i'm not
i'm not committed to doing it perfectly
these guys all work with me i wish you
could see our studio
okay but i got francisco here i got
johnny i got nathan here i got
guys guys do i ever talk about doing
anything perfectly
have i ever said anything about doing
something perfectly
i do it i just do i just do a lot of
stuff okay
i'm like put that stuff on the wall
there you go that's good okay
look man johnny's doing the whole room
that's that that's natalie
there's nathan okay we got a good group
here right so check it out
number one you gotta commit number two
you gotta do
whatever is in front of you just do it
it doesn't need to be approved it
doesn't need to be checked
we're not hunting
like i'm not deer hunting here i'm not
taxi driver
and a deer hunter you understand
we're we're not like i'm not going
public here i'm not trying to raise a
billion dollars
i'm just trying to get my job done it's
an instagram post man
the number one reason businesses fail is
the inability
the inability to sell products in
quantities great enough
and it margins high enough that is the
only reason
you will fail you take too long to go
from the idea
to selling enough products volume at
margins high enough
do that learn to do that
and you can make any dream a reality
okay i want to help the world
this is not taught in schools there's 8
billion people on this planet
and there's no shortage of information
how many have heard this before
knowledge is power
then why are so many people suffering
why are so many people suffering no it
ain't stupid man
we have more information available to us
today than any time in the history of
the world we got too much information at
this point
you got too much information and not
enough action
25 years old i'm selling automobiles i'm
broke
i'm in debt 40 000 in debt
spiritually bankrupt physically bankrupt
hate myself
only thing i had was an opportunity
the car dealer that i worked for took me
back that was an opportunity
don't dismiss the opportunity
you can't go anyplace without
an opportunity no matter how talented
you are
no matter how gifted you are no matter
what god has done for you
without an opportunity you will not
move from your garage your life cannot
improve
without an opportunity it's impossible
you guys don't like sales because you
ain't got any courage
that's why you want to be a you want to
be the vice president of something
that's why you guys want to call it
something else okay most of you in the
room don't even have sales on your card
you you sell real estate for remax okay
or keller
and you don't even have sales on the
card
you're in network marketing you refused
we don't do sales here
what do you do then okay what do you do
i mean i think the company's got a
financial statement
you ever read a financial statement
what's the first line on a financial
statement
huh what's that first line it's the
first line by the way
okay i've seen a bunch of income
statements in my life the first
the first ones are like two to maybe max
four inches long
big companies big giant companies okay i
got five companies they run to one
financial statement
and the top line the top line the sales
line you could call it
i think it's called also what revenue
could be called gross revenue
okay you know people are getting
confused now
okay they start getting away from this
word some some some
college guy came in and said do we can't
call it sales man
we got to call it something like at
least two or three words
i mean i went to harvard it's not about
how much money you make folks
can you use money
can you use it okay look this top these
top lines right here are about
income if you hate sales
you hate income i don't care who you are
i don't care what your age is okay
i spent the first from the age of 25
years old to 45 years old i spent 20
years
thinking small thinking small and taking
too long
i built three little businesses they
were all doing good man they were doing
good three of them man
from scratch first little business i was
a millionaire when i was 30
33 years old punching shoving hard work
man the more money i had the more scared
i was
because i had just enough money to be
scared
as soon as you get a million dollars
you're going to go into terror
i'm telling you you can be like what am
i going to do now
okay i wasn't scared before now i got
something to lose
[Music]
that's why you never want to get your
advice from a millionaire if you're
taking notes
never get your advice from a millionaire
ever
okay this held me down for 20 years
20 years it held me down you looking at
me like huh
i read the millionaire next door what
did the millionaire next door say
buy a used truck and don't go to
starbucks
you say four bucks a day for the next 38
years you're gonna be in heaven no you
ain't
you're gonna be it's dumb man okay if
four dollars is going to break you on
any given day
you're just back to thinking the way you
were thinking when you didn't have
anything
buy everything on sale okay everything
you're going to buy is going to be on
sale you got to get a deal
every time you buy something is that
what your daddy taught you never pay
retail for anything
that means nobody will ever pay you
retail folks when i started twitter
account i had no followers when i
started a facebook account no followers
i was my first follower when i started
instagram account no followers
um i didn't know how to post video i
didn't know how to take a selfie i
didn't know how to do any of this but i
did
have a commitment to grow in my finances
and if you want to grow your finances
attention is the gateway you want to go
to heaven who wants to go to heaven
you got to die i'm just telling you man
you got to die
to go to the heaven
and most people don't want to die they
want to go to heaven but they don't want
to die
most people want money but they're not
willing to get the attention they're not
willing to do what it takes
to get the attention including spending
money
and i would just tell you this if you
want to change your financial condition
the first thing you need to do is go out
and market in the marketplace
so that you can create a lead and not
worry about whether there's roi or not
it's so
that people are like what's the roi dude
what's the roi
if nobody knows you okay what's the roi
if i don't know your name don't know
your company don't know what you do
don't know your service don't know your
product don't know where you're located
what is the roi okay best product does
not win today
the best known product wins you think
starbucks
sells the best coffee please it's nasty
[Music]
okay but it's close
and i know what i'm getting when i get
there mcdonald's they'll sell the best
hamburger
close and available you need to think
way bigger than you're thinking like
i started in the apartment game uh 25
years ago in san diego california my
first deal first deal i ever bought was
one unit
this little yellow house that i paid 78
000
for by the way all this landscaping
that's one of the things i'm known for
i'm like i'm putting trees up there
because that's going to give me some
extra rent it didn't by the way
my next deal was 38 units okay it was
easier buying 38 units and it was one
the only difference was to think i had
to think different
got to make a few more phone calls but
the play is bigger right
the reason people the reason so many
real estate people are like
marginal people no offense raise your
hand if you're marginal
they left all day raise your hand if
you're a liar
look man look i'm marginal to compared
to my potential
the fact that there's people in this
room that don't know me i've written
seven books 13 best-selling business
programs
uh i have i'm probably the top one or
two maybe three social media people in
the world
seven million people on facebook but
seven million people on facebook is
nothing compared to seven
billion people in the world
[Music]
so think big man
problems are opportunities the bigger
the problems
if you could look for the giant problems
on this planet and quit complaining
about them
right and quit blaming somebody about
them and say
man what if i took responsibility for
that problem
because there is money in solving
problems
you solve a problem
you'll end up with money and the bigger
the problem you solve
the bigger the problem you solve the
more money you end up with
first 35 40 years of my life i was being
held back by what i knew
what i thought was the truth it wasn't
the truth these people and companies
that are buying private jets
that are hooking up with whoever they
want when they want that are spending
millions and millions and millions of
dollars on connections
and speed and access
dude what are they doing man what are
they doing okay
they're doing something different than
you and i were taught to do school
systems don't teach you this your mama
didn't teach you this your daddy didn't
teach you this
your family doesn't know this right so
you got to go outside your circle of
influence
and look around
12 14 million 6 million
4 million
and a little guy a little guy right here
got the big jet
on the tarmac how's a little guy like me
end up making it all the way up to food
shake because i studied those guys
and you can do the same thing if you
study hard enough the right people
not those guys those are the pilots okay
see they work for 150 grand a year think
they're they're
they're cutting a big fat hog and they
ask oh i make 175 000
but they stop learning what the owner
knows
okay study man study paid the price
for the information and then pay for the
price of
access to the people and learn from them
if i could go back to my 20 year old
self what i would tell my 20 year old
self
is one thing get your money right son
worry about the money and now i know a
lot of people think that this is not the
thing people should be focused on
however on this planet if you don't get
your money right you're going to be
worried all the debt
all the time you can't take care of your
parents you can't take care of yourself
you can't take care of your rent you
can't live in a nice place you can't
take care of your car
get your money right okay what should
you be spending your money on why do
wealthy people use money not spend money
why do wealthy people buy
businesses they don't buy homes why do
wealthy people use
debt to grow their business they don't
use debt
to consume products and services why do
wealthy people
not invest in 401ks and seps and
retirement accounts they don't even
worry about that they worry about
getting their money soaked
and right that they can go wherever they
want day or night
i love baseball i i i love baseball but
but
but you don't have to love baseball
to be inspired by greatness watch this
watch this
what's this
[Music]
greatness man that's greatness i got
that guy he
you know when you when i watch that i'm
like i wonder how many times he's run
jumped taken flying pitch i mean
thousands and thousands and thousands of
times to get
to have that moment right there so by
the way that's that's in everybody here
okay so if you ever see a great ball
play whether it's football or hockey or
ballet or dancing and you're inspired
it's because it's it's hitting that part
of you that's like you have that in you
everywhere you go you need you need to
confront every time you hit up against
oh the room's 249
the the mill is 25 bucks uh starbucks is
six dollars
the airline flight costs 600 every time
you like oh
okay you need to understand that you're
being reminded you don't have enough
money
it has nothing to do with the price
but but watch how much people
disassociate oh american airlines is
charging too much for that ticket
that has nothing to do with it you don't
you don't make enough money
okay so i had a guy i was in oakland
california
i was flying back and i said uh hey
anybody want to fly home with me the
guy's like i want to fly home with you
i'll do it i said good
i'll be 48 000 for fuel oh oh i don't
want to do it
no you can't do it because you don't
have the money fuel's not the problem
he didn't he doesn't make enough money
so just start flipping things
so like now when i see wagyu remember
that wago we ate
in vegas it was like 115 for a strip
that big
never do it again by the way but the
fact that i complained about it only
means
i don't make enough money
[Music]
and if the wagu's too much money if the
115 for a little strip of wagyu is too
much money
what does that say about what i'm
selling my products for
not charging them up can't get enough i
have this idea so it's really
to me it's really we go to paris man and
we go to the chanel store and there's
people in line
in line out the front door at the chanel
store i'm like oh my god
great experience for me how much money
is on this planet
go to monaco see the yachts 200 million
240
300 million dollars 300 millions they
cost 30 million a year to take care of
them
great experience flying private been a
great experience for me
okay guy has five jets not not not he's
not complaining about a first-class seat
anymore
and the peanuts he's got five jets
different level man all of a sudden you
start thinking different start asking
different
start working deals different 52 years
old and i had a problem
i was depressed i wasn't satisfied
i was hungry but didn't know what to do
i had businesses i had money
i had a whole bunch of stuff but i'm
like dude what am i doing now
i'm bickering with elena we had our kids
we had the first two kids and we're like
okay we got a kid i'm being a parent now
okay i'm being a married guy right i'm
being a businessman and i'm unhappy
and then i start asking people what's
wrong man what's wrong what's wrong with
me man
something wrong with me something wrong
with me oh yeah and as soon as you say
is something wrong with me
everybody's got an opinion oh yeah man
man you got a disease man you got a
problem you got issues man you work too
much
you're a work addict you you you you're
insecure your daddy died your daddy died
and left a hole in you
left a hole in me i can't go on a
vacation
i want to do something man
doing less has never solved my problems
doing less moderation has never solved a
problem for me
the problem that i've had in my life
okay was not my marriage
it's not okay i'm not a bad parent i
wasn't helping enough people
you should be up here you should be
dropping out of the ceiling
you should be helping more people i just
got awarded
awarded this deal 92.5 million dollars
31 acres of land you know my buddy evan
carmichael talks about dream believe
yeah but dream what and believe what
believe you pay your bills i believe you
can
one day write a check for 60 million
bucks what do you believe
what are you going to dream of like
literally i think people's dreams are
one of the things holding them back
because they don't know how to dream i
don't know how big to dream
this is doable for any person i don't
care who you are anybody could do this
deal
anybody could do that deal i know the
guys that own private jets
they're no smarter than anybody else
they're not smarter they don't work
probably don't even work any harder
but they did they did think bigger and
they get in the in
and you can't you can't catch whales in
it in a
in a bowl goldfish bowl so you got to be
in the right
in the right stream of traffic money
follows attention
money follows attention
[Applause]
how much attention can you guys get okay
most of you can't get attention because
your mom and daddy said
don't get too much attention
don't get too much attention be seen
and not heard fly under the radar
because if you get too much attention
they're gonna shoot you down
right how many hurt this before fly
under the radar man stay low man don't
let anybody see
you making moves don't make moves man
don't make moves
and then everybody wonders why can't i
get above
strangers have everything you want
everything you want a stranger has it
it will be strangers that will grow your
business
it will be strangers that put your kids
through schools it will be strangers
that make your dreams a reality
strangers have everything you want but
you were taught not to talk to them
we can't afford that how many have told
your kids about that before we can't do
that bike
we can't buy the bike right you told
your kids that because you were told
that
right we don't tell our kids that how
many of you have told us kids be careful
that's why you guys think so much you
got you got dave ramsey on tv
saying total freedom
comes from not having debt
okay you got you you flip channels and
you go to susie
you can't afford that okay i'm going to
tell you
do you can afford anything no no no
hey debt's not your problem okay i got
four
four i probably got 500 million dollars
worth of debt today
500 million i wish it was 5 billion
yeah man i had to get over drugs went to
treatment center spent 28 days in the
treatment center
when i was 25 my mom my brother my
sister all gave up on me
like they're like enough that's how bad
a trouble i was and i was using
i was using drugs every 45 minutes
i wasn't using drug once or twice a day
i was using once or twice an hour
whatever you're not going to do with the
business me you probably shouldn't be
doing period
so i had to clean up i had to clean up
my deal man
28 days i got 28 days first 28 days of
my life in seven years that i didn't use
drugs i was like
man what am i gonna do now my fear
wasn't using drugs again
my fear was what am i gonna do with all
my time
so when you see me run right now i'm
running from one thing to the next thing
i'm trying to stay busy because as long
as i stay busy i don't get in trouble
by the way i'm the guy that couldn't pay
his rent
275 a month in rent and i couldn't pay
it most of the time
so at 25 i recommitted to my education
but this time i started studying not
things that were in books but people
that it actually
created wealth not people that had made
money but people that had created wealth
this is completely different
i was no longer studying accounting and
economics i was studying
wealthy people and only wealthy people
i'm not talking about the doctor
that was a neighbor that makes a million
dollars a year and he's working 18 hours
a day and he hates his job
right he's working seven days a week he
can't ever spend time with family i'm
talking about the yacht people
i'm talking about the people that are
spending as much time as they want on
vacation
i'm talking about the car dealer that
had uh 28 car dealerships
or 82 car dealerships that has
indisposable money i'm talking about the
walton money i'm talking about
the waltons last week increased their
net worth by 11 billion dollars and they
haven't worked for 30 years
that's the kind of wealth i started
studying i started reading barons in the
wall street journal and i quickly
realized something
that the wealthy people had financial
freedom and no one else did
okay a very small percentage of people
lots of people have money
my uncle had millions of dollars he was
terrified about his money
wouldn't spend it acted like a miser
buried money in the backyard
i realized my parents had it wrong the
information i had that was wrong
and this is the number one thing i want
you to get out tonight
the information you have is wrong
the wealthy talk differently than the
middle class
i watched my mom and my dad i started
comparing the wealthy people
to what my dad did my dad worked every
day every day of the week if he wasn't
working at the office
he was working in the yard they saved
money they cut their own grass
okay we ate all our food we turned the
lights off we didn't waste
anything and that was uncertainty it was
insecurity and it was fear and it
perpetuated
uncertainty insecurity and fear and and
all the lessons about money money
doesn't grow on trees a penny saved is a
penny earned
eat all your food people are starving
okay money
money you don't waste it don't play with
it all that
creates insecurity and it's incorrect
so you just got to say i'm going to get
more done and quit talking about all
this bs that you're telling yourself
i don't have time i don't have time i
ain't got time i'm tired it don't matter
man
commit to getting more done the more you
get done the more you
will earn period in the story
right so i get more done than elena does
elena if
elena sat here right now she would say
this man is a damn machine
why why do i get more done because i
post i post without looking at it
i simply get more done why because i'm
committed to getting more done
i'm not i'm not committed to doing it
perfectly
i know this if you want things to change
they can change
and they're not going to change just
because you pray just because you wish
just because you hope and they won't
change just because your family wants to
change it it did not change and still
until i started getting
information and if you're taking notes
today
it didn't start changing until i started
getting rid of information one of the
most important things that happened to
me in my life was to get
rid of information
a man told me once he's like hey look
man if things aren't going well
somebody or something is causing it not
to go well let me agree with that
statement
okay things aren't going well something
or
someone is causing
things not to go well okay and before
you guys take on the republicans or the
democrats
or the conspiracy he said grant before
you take on other people
why don't you just take on these 24
inches right here bud
okay before you take on changing the
whole world once you handle like
between your shoulders because you got
your hands full
different game today folks different
game man everything's changing remember
when you waited for a taxi cab
remember that when was that how many
people on this planet
complained about having to wait on a
dirty cab
millions and millions and millions of
people said oh my gosh
hey man let's just send it to him if you
can close the distance between an
idea and money okay
you'll get rich when i was a kid when i
was growing up
the guy that the guy that knew how to
take care of his environment was my dad
i was eight years old and then this dude
this dude controlled
everything in this environment
and he left early for work he came home
late
took care of his family and you knew he
never gave anybody a lecture about what
to do
he he just he was a good example
and um and he had the money and he made
the money
we were middle cla middle class family
so we were like
little red brick house white brick
actually white brick house
about 1400 square feet seven people
lived in it
and my dad i could tell my dad was
trying to get somewhere he was trying to
move us up
he was trying and he wasn't trying to
brag he was trying to take care of
and so i was watching that right and i
watched where this guy
he he's the one that made the decision
where we went how long we stayed
and i started associating that the money
maker makes the rules
this is what elena was talking about you
know there's around the money i make the
rules around the money around other
things elena makes the rules so
you got to know what you're good at what
your job is and what your role is my dad
and my mom knew their roles
[Music]
the problem with that is when my dad
died suddenly at 52 years old
my mom was left to do something she
didn't
she didn't have she was not skilled up
to do
and and i was 10 and i wasn't i didn't
know how to help my mom
and my dad left a little bit of
insurance money from the from the life
insurance or the death insurance
better better it's really called death
insurance just can't sell it if they
call it that
and my mom
didn't know how long that money would
last so immediately after my dad died
when my
mom should have been in grief she she
went immediately into massive fear
and i could see it i could sense it as a
10 year old my mom was in fear
every day clipping coupons saving money
you know turn the lights off eat all
your food
it was constant messages go across town
to get gas
like everything can't buy strawberries
today
you know they'll be they'll be 20 cents
cheaper tomorrow
everything was about
fear
and so i i couldn't do anything about it
or didn't think i could do anything
about it
and i just kept telling myself one day
one day i'm gonna be in a position to
change this
and i think that really drives me today
to like
take care of
people not be in that situation again
you don't have more money folks because
now it's not it's not because you don't
work it's not because you're not a good
person
it's not because you overspend it's not
because you got too much debt
it's not because you don't bust your ass
it's because your money doesn't bust
its ass your money is lazy if your money
was employees you would fire your money
so here's the rules okay number one the
the money the extra money should go into
something that gives you money
you want your money to have babies the
golden goose is no long
no longer good if she doesn't have
eggs the only thing that makes the
golden goose valuable is the fact that
the golden goose lays
legs lays eggs so if you just study the
wealthiest families
in the world not just in america in the
world over long periods of time
look at the queen the queen of england
this much property and one of the
richest families in the world why
they get cash flow every month
from india from england from ireland
from all over the world why why are the
princes in
saudi arabia so wealthy because they
have constant
inflow of money coming from the land
that produces the oil the oil comes out
of the land
and produces cash flow the railroads the
railroads back in the day what'd they do
they got all this land together and then
they rented that land out to everybody
around
it why do all the teachers credit unions
take all the money from all the teachers
around america
and then they start investing in real
estate that produces cash flow
so they can distribute back to their
members
i'm always going to come back to this
one story look real assets
that produce real cash flow every month
when it pays you every month and you're
getting reminded every month i got a
check
i got a little hundred dollar check i
got a 200 check this month i got a 13
000
check today from one of my properties
every month i get a check for 13 grand
from that property
it's 150 000 a year it didn't start like
that it used to be like 1300 bucks 1300
then it was 26
then it was 5 000. next thing you know
it's 13 grand that's one property
pays me every month property just sits
there
okay it just sits there it might not
even change in value it just sits there
and produces cash flow anything that
produces cash flow
will be worth more money tomorrow that's
why netflix is valuable
why because people pay a lot of cash
into
netflix and even if netflix loses money
today
some company will find netflix desirable
for one reason cash flow is king
before you start getting all oh god damn
dude look this is stupid
these cars that you're seeing people buy
i think 50 cent got six of them for
christmas or something
i got my wife a culinard and i got
myself this
this is ridiculous you don't need to go
out and buy these cars
okay this is without a doubt complete
waste of money
and unlike unlike some of the people
that are out buying them because there's
a lot of young kids right now thinking
oh i'm gonna go buy a lambo i'm gonna
get a ferrari i'm gonna
go buy me a rose i watched a 24 year old
kid by rolls royce
i'm like man i don't even look good on
you even if you can't afford what you
see right here is completely ridiculous
but years 35 years of hard work not just
hard work
but making good decisions and putting
the money away putting the money away
and not doing this kind of stuff
put all this stuff off don't do this
right now okay pay the price right now
work hard get great at your job get
great at whatever you do so good that
people are like man you're the best well
who are you what are you on they start
asking questions about wow
what makes you so unique then
you're going to start getting paid more
there's no way on this planet that if
people don't if people start talking
about how exceptional you are
you will get paid more at some point
when you do take that money and invest
it in something where you can't lose it
where it pays you every month and one
day in the future
it'll be worth more than it is today do
that for years
it might take 10 years 15 years 20 years
i'm just starting to enjoy my life a lot
of hard work man
if you can't stay connected to the y i
don't mean why am i doing this
but you got to dig down the y behind the
y behind the y
right why do i want to lose weight why
do i want to be in better shape
why uh because it because it because
it's going to make me healthy but why do
you want to be healthy
why did i start investing in real estate
and by the way why did i start making
more money so i could have more money to
invest in real estate
why do you want to make more money so
you can have more money to invest in
real estate why oh
because i want to spend more time with
my kids man because i want to be on a
vacation with my kids and not worry
about
what we're doing i want to be able to go
to sleep or go travel or do whatever i
want
and i got money coming in and i want to
be able to take care of my parents and
my church and my charity
i want to take care of stuff after i die
that's why i invest in real estate the
why behind the why
behind the why man what would you do
without what would you do if somebody
took all your money ain't nobody gonna
take all my money
okay nobody can take all my money nobody
thinks big enough
you can't steal all my money dude a
thief never thinks big enough that's why
he steals
[Music]
a thief steals less than he could have
made honestly
okay but if i didn't have any money
today
take away everything whatever that means
everything is i'm still left with what
i'm grant cardone i got courage
i have creativity if i was 20 years old
again
no more drinking no more drugging no
more weekends
until i get my money right just like job
sales second thing i would do is this i
would invest
my extra time not my money my extra time
i would invest learning about real
estate without a doubt
if i would have been doing this at 20
years old i'd be worth over a billion
dollars today
all i had to do was focus different what
i did was i got caught up in this first
job
and i started thinking about how good i
was doing
one day looked up i was 35 years old 33
years old actually and my uncle says
you need to start paying attention to
your money
to money working he said it to me one
time man one piece of advice i got
from my uncle he's like you need to
start paying attention you need to get
your money working i'm like
okay thanks you need to hate your life
you guys don't need to like
i'm good i'm all happy i'm good i'm i'm
living the dream you
need to get so disgusted i told you this
eight years ago get so disgusted with
your life
get so like you hate your life so much
that that the thing that that where you
go every day is a solution to getting
the life you want
how do you keep your mojo going like
it it's like it's like you got more
energy i said well it's a beautiful
having a beautiful wife
thank you handsome women women
women let's just call us baby women are
the super
uh motivators of the universe this is my
muse right now oh
god in addition to the muse though
okay okay it's a new me this year folks
really in addition to the muse you guys
got to have a pull
you need to have a pull you're like man
why how do you stay
how do you guys stay so motivated it's
the pull
it's not the push the ball players i'll
say me me and tim grover will talk about
this
jordan wins a ring and he's like okay
now what everybody else is out you know
drinking champagne
but this the true champions are like
what's the next thing what's the next
move what do we do next like they need
the next thing to keep
on going but when am i ever going to be
satisfied you need a power
you're never going to be satisfied and
if you are by the way by the way if you
are satisfied you quit
you put you put your sword down you quit
fight play in the game it makes me more
hungry
the speed at which
you commit
determines your velocity
how fast i can commit to something will
determine how fast i can move into that
thing and how much power i have okay
the speed at which you commit the longer
you take to commit to something the less
impact it's going to have on your
community
on yourself on your life on your money
your finances i don't care if it's
rehabbing your kitchen
buying a house and making an investment
in real estate the speed at which you
can commit let's do it
dude i want to collaborate with people i
don't want to compete anymore i'm done
with the
competition so when you hear when you
hear some such
things i think of me you everybody
teaches me you hear all that early sales
stuff for me
i was in such a competition mode
it was i was competing with everybody i
thought it was me against
everybody and really it's just been in
the last
since we did that first growth
conference and we had other people on
stage and i didn't do
like i didn't do any of the speaking
yeah i was just introducing people
doing interviews and walking uh doing
doing q and a's
five side chats even the second even the
second one even russell brunson says
dude why would you
why are you giving up all your stage
time to other people because i want to
collaborate
yeah and and but then we figured that
the other people don't really know how
to do it yet
like they're like hey follow my
instagram i'm like that's not a
collaboration
we don't care about your instagram when
i took spent six million dollars trying
to get 30 000 people in the room
yeah right now we care about where is
everybody going
for the next through next year and 2020.
your surroundings have to change
okay the people your network your
scenery
you will not change your life until you
change the people
in your life if your friends aren't
changing
you ain't either my daddy abandoned me
my sister's not going to like hearing
that because she's like oh my god
he was good to you he died
he left me too soon
period call it whatever you want okay
he left me too soon he left my brother
too soon
okay me and my brother without a dad man
tremendous amount of energy
[Music]
same kind of like like just imagine me
as a 10 year old in louisiana
with a weapon
right i'm 10 years old we we had a 22
rifle
i'm out shooting everything that moves
cars
[Music]
anything anything and everything i'm
wild man i'm wild i got all this energy
and i don't have a dad and i'm angry
i told my mom when i was 16 years old
one day
one day i'm going to be successful one
day
one day i'm going to be successful and
one day i'm going to help a lot of
people
and i said that to her because i wanted
somebody to help me
see i've always loved helping people
always
i am most happy when i'm helping someone
else
nothing to do with money if i can help
somebody
not give them something but if i can
actually help somebody to feel better
about themselves
to know what to do in a phone call to
know what to do on a sales call
to know how to follow up their
girlfriend or their boyfriend or to
solve some problem in their life or how
to get some money
if i can help somebody know how to do
that i know i contributed to their life
are y'all ready for 2019 are y'all ready
cause i'm ready
i'm ready freddy okay okay
look i gotta carry i carry a fire
extinguish with me everywhere i
go i looped it onto my pants
because my game's so hot that's right
that's right
[Music]
all right yeah oh yeah
put out put out my game hot my game hot
okay yeah pull the pin
pull the pin again oh [ __ ] you see how
hot my game is
oh yeah we should have done this inside
huh
oh yeah
ho ho ho ho
let's go 2019 i'm a bus chef
hey
[Music]
oh
[Music]
sabrina can't set the right goals right
now everybody agree with that
sabrina can't she can't pick up 200
pounds
you understand she could fly on a jet
one of my kids has never been on a
commercial airline she's like
papa will i ever get to fly a commercial
i hope not i hope you never have to go
through that
it's wrong i did three million miles so
you don't have to
peanuts i didn't want and i was doing
that on thanksgiving holidays to go to
canada where they were they were still
transacting
business super bowls i've missed ball
games i've missed
my buddies were traveling seeing the
world and i didn't have any of those
experiences
it's been 30 years 30 years it's
probably going to be 30 years for you
too
it's going to be 30 years of it are you
willing to pay the price
if anybody thinks you're going to be
successful without paying that price
you're wrong earn money learn how to
store the money
and learn how to use it because if you
can't do this if you can't flow the
money back out
if you're sitting on a grand right now
or two grand or five grand
make it official that you're broke
do not try to save five grand
it's no money just
make it official get rid of it
and be broke because you're broke
already
and maybe you'll hustle now like you
need to replace your reserves
that's why when i earn some money i
store it okay
if if i store 30 million dollars i know
i'm getting rid of it twice a year
i dump everything i have entire every
penny i have
does not go into some emergency account
it goes into an asset
that will make babies or make me known
and you guys can do this everybody in
the room can do this okay if i can do
this you guys can do this
you need a network a team of people
around you that can hold you accountable
you will go nowhere by yourself not even
jesus went by himself
nobody goes by themselves nobody
all right you have more potential you
know if that's the answer to that
get there be vip while you're there too
by the way
vip have a vip experience
if you can't vip yourself why do you
think somebody else is going to treat
you
like a vip jesus christ man
what are you guys doing man oh my god
you used the lord's name in vain yes so
what i do a lot of other good [ __ ]
you don't really think they're like like
he's gonna keep me out because i said
that do you now come on keep it real man
i help millions of people
every year all right keep it real folks
come on man
come on think a little for yourself okay
your best thinking got you in the
situation you're in right now you got
money problems health problems
networking problems
you're introverted uh you don't know
where to invest your money
you got your money sitting in wall
street you got a house you got a bad
marriage you got kids that don't like
you or kids on
drugs or you're using drugs too much
dude your best thinking got you in this
right now you need to become
a very important person okay how do you
become a very important person
you spend time with other people that
believe
themselves to be very important people
the website is 10x growthcon dot com
fortunate vip
10x growthcon.comvip
i could give you a million dollar son
but it would put you in prison
forever you probably blow it in one day
too i'd rather teach you how to make a
hundred million
okay all right guys god bless you
appreciate you following me on facebook
please tell your friends about me
um 10x or die that's what i say
and die quick
i wish somebody told me about 10x when i
was 20 years old you guys that are 20
years old man
listen to what i'm telling you man your
buddies that
want just enough just enough to go out
friday night just enough to pay the
bills just enough to pay to rent
just enough to smoke your little weed
dude they're selfish little
little all you influencers out there
want to just just enough money to fly
you know get an upgrade for your first
class yo
all you guys out there just want fame
but not fortunate you a
i don't know where i am most the time i
don't know what day it is i don't know
what time it is i just know hey i got
this moment man
right here let's make the most of this
moment i don't know if i live once or
twice
okay i know this i need to take
advantage of what i have right now and i
can't do that by myself i don't want to
be by myself
we don't want to just be the four of us
i don't want to just be me
elena sabrina and scarlett i want to i
want i want a nation i don't want a
tribe
i don't want a tribe i want friends all
over the world i want sabrina and
scarlet when they grow up
and they go to to switzerland they have
friends
in switzerland okay if the world falls
apart
we have friends in oklahoma or in
central
or maybe i gotta go to south america for
a while maybe i gotta go hang out
okay i will not fulfill my mission my
mission is to help people
i will be known for the people i help
not the money i made nobody's gonna
remember nobody's gonna say 50 years
from now 100 years from now
oh grant cardone had a great jet nobody
nobody will ever mention that
my books might live on okay my audio
will
guarantee you my audio will live long
after i'm dead
but your memories with me you using our
technologies okay
will live on forever you live on through
other people walt disney did it
he lives on today man okay
build a legacy folks build a legacy put
yourself out there okay
10x your lives 10x in the lives of the
people around you
give more than you take give more than
you take
give more than you take and i promise
you you will get more
than you ever dreamed of i'm getting
ready to do a real estate conference for
a thousand
experienced and mature real estate
investors
if you knew what i was going to share
with them the one
biggest most important number in all of
real estate investing there's one thing
if you read my book you know what it is
i'm gonna share it with them today and
it's gonna blow them top off their heads
there's some people in the room that are
retired from apartment investing
and they're gonna i guarantee you when
i'm done today
they're gonna be like honey what was
rethinking getting out of this game
we gotta get back in it we did it wrong
cause we did it small
hey if you're not investing in
apartments seriously if you're not
investing in apartments if you don't
know the game had to learn the game
learn the game
figure the game out i promise you with
every
fiber of my being i believe that
apartment investing will
prove to be over the next 25 years the
single best investment
up here that you can make that you can
possibly make okay
if your life is not the way it should be
then you should hate yourself right now
i don't blame you you should
the best way but dude i hated my [ __ ]
before i loved my [ __ ] i hated myself so
bad i couldn't look in the mirror
jared told me the other day he's like
you don't have a mirror in your bathroom
let me bring you in there right now sure
there's no mirror in there check this
out
i said dude i don't need a mirror i
remember you know what that bathroom i
remember having an apartment where i
couldn't put a mirror
on the wall broke it i broke the mirror
look at that right there dang no mirror
i told chair yesterday i said dude
i don't have a mirror i said i don't
care i don't need to look at myself
i remember when i looked at myself and i
hated myself
broke the mirror out of my bathroom
because i couldn't look at my face
because the mirror reminded me every
time i had a mirror i was putting
something on it to put it in my face
i hated myself man hated myself didn't
have any money
had all this potential overdosing daily
that's one man you want to change you
got a bunch of potential tell you tell
yourself the truth
okay do you have more potential than
you're using
ask yourself right now just ask yourself
just meditate on this a second
do i have more potential than i'm using
you guys ask yourself that [ __ ] every
morning when you wake up man what do you
say to yourself in the morning
first thing i do in the morning i wake
up and say do i have more potential
thank you alex
do i have more potential than i'm using
dude if i do
if it's even this much then i gotta get
the [ __ ] up and go get it
this is where god lives dude this is the
spiritual part of life
is the seeking of potential not the
seeking of sin
of serenity and happiness serenity and
happiness are [ __ ] selfish
commodities it's about me man for me to
seek my potential the next level
means i gotta give up what i have that's
where god lives man
god's proud of grant cardone you know
what a bunch of humans don't like grant
god loves grant yo you know what because
god's like dude that guy
he will put it out there you guys all
praying you know what my prayer is my
prayer is not talking to god my prayer
is taking action
i've been there i've been busted broke
beat up
i've been i've been at a point in my
life where i thought i thought less than
me
than anyone thought of me how many have
been there
dude how do i get the right girl the
right family the right money the right
company the right employees
i don't even like me
[Music]
i'm like what happened to me man what
happened
i had more money when i was eight than
when i was 25.
what the hell happened i liked myself
more when i was six years old then i was
25 years old
what happened to me now if you look at
me today
six years old and 57 dude i'm kind of
digging myself right now
i like who i am man i've spent the last
years just doing one thing dude working
on who i am number one most important
thing warren buffett says
and i study a lot of people okay this
year i'll probably spend this year
between mentors which really my mentor
is just the guys to hook up he's
hooking me up with other players between
mentors
i don't think i say the word right uh
books courses i'll go off for three
weeks and just do a course you guys
worry about a weekend
i can't get away for a weekend dude i'll
go for three weeks and just do courses
i'll probably spend 400 grand this year
on me
i'm worth it man how am i not worth 400
grand look you worried about 400 grand
how are you going to get 400 million
so you and i were brought up to worry
about what
this what's in your pocket
[Music]
right i mean i used to squeeze the
quarter so hard it fly
and scream
look look everybody worries about this
right
but whose money is this somebody else's
money man
i've already got a workout in spent time
with my kids
did a project at my office because we're
doing some construction there
on my way to an event and then we'll
leave there go to another event in
another city
about 2 000 miles away all in the name
of business that's what i say my
brothers
my sisters my nephews and my nieces
all business all weekend the best things
that have happened to me in my life was
when i left my room
my house even the city that i lived in
and um i think we stay home too much
29 years old left the house moved to
houston
i was terrified i know somebody think oh
man great ain't scared of nothing
i was so scared to move out of lake
charles
it was like one of the most terrifying
things i've ever done in my life
once i got there i was like that i don't
even know what i was scared about
my daddy told me dr kara our local
doctor he was the most successful doctor
in the
in in uh we knew both the most
successful doctors dr care and dr
morin right and dr care was at the house
and they're drinking martinis
i'm like damn i'm gonna do that too i'm
a dream martini and i'm gonna be james
bond
right and dr carr came up to me and says
give me a dollar i had a dollar too he's
like give me that dollar
i'm like i ain't giving you a dollar my
daddy said
never deny a man in power
never deny a man in power
okay never talk poorly about somebody
in power push power to power
that's a good investment folks okay if
you're taking notes write this down
push power to power people that are
doing good things
people that are making a difference
people that are out there
push power to power and ignore everyone
else
we don't help people that have nothing
i'm telling you right now i do not help
people that have nothing
i have i help people that have something
and want to make it more i'm not talking
about money right now
if somebody thinks they have nothing i'm
not helping that person if they think
they have nothing i can't help them if
you think you have something
and that you're not broke i can help you
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
it's saying hey man if you got a million
dollars you're basically just a freaking
deadbeat
and that your daddy didn't tell you that
if you didn't have any more income
and you were how old are you
you're 27 years old i'm gonna do this at
47 i'm gonna do it at uh
at 65. 27
you don't have any more income how long
will that money last
at 4 000 a month you got 25 years
where can you live on four thousand
dollars a month you'd have to live on
four thousand dollars a month
for 25 years you will be 52 years old my
friend
and dead broke number one thing you got
to do is this
you got to change the target and you
need to look at the target daily
the target you have the wrong target
right now if you're struggling you have
the wrong target
when you change the target everything
changes
now and i started with zero just so you
guys know i didn't have anything
okay so look it's simple target what's
your new target freedom
yeah freedom but but but let's put my a
number on it
your first target should be 10 million
and nothing short of that number one the
target number two
you need to get your income to a place
this is a fascinating concept right here
okay if you can do this i guarantee
you'll be rich you need to get your
income
not to what pays your bills but to where
you can save
40 of your gross income
is saved all right so now now when you
do this math you're like dude how much
money do i actually need let's kick this
up to 20 grand
at 20 grand what happens you're saving
eight
storage you're paying eight
and now you can live on four see now
this is the right way to do a budget
you make thirty thousand twelve is going
to storage
12 is going to the ir and the s
and that leaves you with six so now you
can start seeing
do you got to be somewhere north of 300
grand a year this is what they don't
teach you at harvard
you got to be somewhere north of 360 a
year before you even
have money to live on unless you're just
you know you're direct you're just an
irresponsible human being
that that's you know not putting storing
money away for the future
okay now you're saving 12 grand a month
that's 144 000
in one year in 10 years that's 1.4
million dollars in 10 years you're a
millionaire
stored you guys need to be heavily money
motivated from a survival standpoint
okay number three thing you're gonna
do you're gonna go broke right here
and invest
the storage storage has to get invested
the golden goose is only good if she
lays eggs otherwise you can kill her eat
her fur chicken
need eggs bait money needs to make
babies
right so your goal right here is to
invest
to invest the storage money and continue
to do that
until this money over here the passive
money
is equal to
your income
[Music]
right so what would i do i'd go out i'm
going to make 30 grand
i'm going to store 12 i'm going to pay
the irs i'm going to live on six
warren buffett says don't lose money
number one number two don't lose money
i would tell you number three don't lose
money and that's the reality of the
situation that's what peter
field was saying a single digit
millionaire
cannot even provide themselves with
their own
personal defense in america
okay hulk hogan all that money hulk
hogan made he blew it all
he blew it all probably buying hair
pieces
okay he blew it all he blew it all ended
up with a little money thought he was
the [ __ ] oh man i got a little money
until he had that freaking lawsuit
and then he can't even defend himself so
it happens to a lot of people
how many how many of you know a family
member lost their job
okay how many of you have a family
member where the kid got a drug
addiction he had to go to
rehab for 30 days and it cost 40 grand
bad [ __ ] happens how many of you know
somebody got cancer
okay how many know somebody in a car
accident cost three or four hundred
grand
what happens okay the problem is not
that [ __ ] happens
happens and people aren't ready for it
oh god i can't believe this happened to
me
oh [ __ ] really goddamn you've been
around long enough
right how many of you can't swim
you live on a planet with water i'm just
saying you might want to get a swimming
lesson it's a wet planet
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days check the link right
here below me or if you want to know how
to 10x your life with grant cardone
check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there